foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
come on
no I thought I lost up time I just
myself hello everyone this is your daily
dose of Internet this is Criminal oh
that was criminal I win
[Music]
what's good Turtle Squad it's your boy
the heck
[Music]
I'm too good at this game I'm gonna win
this thing oh baby and then this
is always the next move oh he
surrendered I knew it guys we're
Geniuses
ready they have this chest Reddit that's
just terrible
in the computer
[Music]
welcome back everyone
welcome back everyone to coverage of POG
Champs five it's day number two uh day
number one in the books yesterday we had
some really exciting matchups we had an
extremely exciting technical delay uh
today we've also had a little fair share
of drama but we're ready for a great day
of Chess I'm Olivia Rosman I'm joined
today by Grandmaster and chess boxing
middleweight champion Amman Hamilton
Amman how are we doing hey Levy it's
great to be here yeah it's a familiar
voice uh on the call with me I you
called my chess boxing fight so good to
be on the call with you now as well in
the booth I'm excited for day two of POG
Champs Levy I mean if it's anything like
day one I think that's what POG Champs
is all about little uh disconnection
issues there little problems here and
there I mean what would it be without
our fair share of uh of drama yeah we
already got off to a good start some of
you may have shown up about an hour ago
for the matchup xqc versus squeak some
technical difficulties uh have prevented
that match from happening this time not
on chess.com but we still have a whole
broadcast ahead so listen knock knock on
wood everything stays good uh let's
remind everybody of the event format and
what were he what we're what we're doing
what this is all about
four groups four players each uh which
means 16 players today we're only going
to be seeing four of them but more on
that later uh the top two from every
group advances to a championship bracket
bottom to go to a consolation bracket
nobody uh gets knocked out in the group
stage and actually this is the first box
Champs that will be hosted live uh the
finals will be hosted live in Los
Angeles on August the 18th uh
Amman
that is sick by the way yeah can I just
say like a live finals I actually read
that Levy in like in the rules ahead of
time and I was like ah they must must
have typed something wrong but that
sounds hype so I can't wait to see that
yeah yeah I mean I don't know if they're
gonna be playing on computers I don't
know if they're going to be playing face
to face over the board but I'm assuming
there will be a computer in between them
just a friendly reminder this is what
our groups look like uh group a at the
top right now we've got Sea Dog Gastly
on top of Group B yesterday uh Group C
got underway with just one matchup uh
and today that will not make any further
progress because the xqc squeaks match
has been postponed and Group D is on
strike uh they have not played at all
they are not playing today I really hope
they're playing tomorrow uh I'm on which
of these groups sticks out to you well
Levy you know Group D really sticks out
to me it just there's so much happening
I mean four-way tie for first uh over in
group D so riveting stuff uh over there
but in other news you know I'm also of
course focused on the matches that we
have today because these matches will
change and will shake up the the groups
that they're in we obviously have you
know Sea Dog who's a guy that's uh been
on the chess brought channel before so
familiar with him uh myself and uh what
about you Levy these uh these names
household to you
well yesterday yeah I actually three of
these people are coming back to play who
played yesterday in day one we've got
three and three individuals who played
day one and day two we got a whole group
that can't even get underway I don't
know what's going on there's some
contract holds up hold UPS or something
we know in the UFC sometimes the Champs
never fight or something like that
um see dog got off to a good start
yesterday so did Jarvis although he did
lose his match against Frank so I'm
excited for that one uh the main event
though ghastly sapnap that's that's
gonna be a barn burner they're they're
very evenly matched they're both around
seven eight hundred sapnap I know
personally uh he really really wants to
win this event so does Gastly probably
right uh and also he does music and you
all love music over there so that's a
collab we gotta see I know like I I was
looking into this and and I was uh
learning that there was gonna be a DJ
competing I said okay I I'm already
gonna have my uh my bias in my in my
right pocket there so hope he'll hope he
does well I'll just go ahead and say it
um but that's uh that's really cool to
see him competing in here Levy yeah
apparently he's had like a really quick
ramp up you know so now you got a chess
and a d he does the chess and the DJing
so doesn't vote us uh my co-host
yesterday so yeah you could you could do
collab with both or one no pressure
whatsoever I enjoyed seeing YouTube uh
yesterday Levy I'm just gonna say I
watched the show you guys always a great
dynamic between YouTube yeah it's uh
it's like crazy little cousin energy you
know uh there was we we talked about
everything yesterday from from chess to
my lack of sparring to Andrea's
ex-boyfriends that was somewhere in the
middle there right so yeah I don't know
if we're gonna you know uh do that on on
today's show or if we're gonna focus on
the players but here's a player card for
you uh because Sea Dog is going to play
Jarvis so we're going to throw that up
on the screen uh Sea Dog is a YouTuber a
podcaster a voice actor in fact he had
his very first like very very big I
think voice acting role recently he was
um he was in the video game uh honkai
star rail which was really cool he won
the best philanthropic stream event uh
in 2023 at the streamer Awards and he he
did it again this year when he cycled
across Japan he is all in one in slap
chessbox wait is he didn't he win am I
going insane did he lose against Ludwig
I thought no the library one I thought
that was just honestly it was just like
slap boxing there was no chess involved
unless I missed the chess part so maybe
they had a private match where he lost
also yeah was it a sanctioned bout like
are you 1-0 in in real chess boxing is
that your record now I I I'd like to say
yes on on my behalf so yeah you know
what we'll go ahead and we'll we'll give
that match a sanction as well and shout
out to him he's watching us right now we
can't hear him but he's definitely
watching us and he's reacting and now
we're reacting to this wow that was like
a Hall of Mirrors there that was cool um
and his opponent is Jarvis we saw Jarvis
play yesterday at least I did I don't
know if people in the chat uh had an
opportunity to Jarvis yesterday played
his first games of Chess against a human
being uh in 17 years apparently he is a
YouTuber a twitch streamer he's got over
600 million views he's a three-time
streaming Awards commentary nominee and
yeah I'm on I don't know if you had a
chance to look at his games yesterday
but not bad for a guy that hasn't played
nearly two decades I I was gonna make
the same comment um shout out to Jarvis
because you know he he came in here
maybe the expectations he set for
himself weren't too high I thought he
showed up and showed out I'm really
excited to see how he plays today but
look at him he's he's just he's a gamer
man he's there he's got the headphones
on he's ready to play Levy I I think
he's out for blood today
he isn't you know I gotta tell you uh I
I feel extremely extremely uh uh like
like diminished right now because there
are three people out of four that have
been involved in combat with another
human Sea Dog the slapping you you chest
box I mean it it was kind of a chess but
it was like 15 seconds you know you got
it done but Jarvis also wasn't Creator
Clash right so I gotta fight somebody
man this is uh yeah I was gonna say
there's there seems to be someone left
out here uh Levy so uh yeah this might
turn into another stream just like
yesterday where we're like Levy where's
the sparring man
speaking of uh would you would you I
don't know if you've commented on this
would you do a Creator Clash would you
do like a pure boxing in the future so
the Creator Clash I was gonna say is
pure boxing uh even chest boxing I've
commented on before and I don't even
think I have a chess box again it took
like it took a lot out of me just to set
time aside I took it pretty seriously so
I don't know if it's something for me
again but I would 100 get involved in a
production like from a commentary role
or something I mean look at me I belong
in a booth Levy I'm I'm done I'm done
were you in the best shape of your life
when all of that was said and done I
oh cause I had to gain 15 pounds and I
promise you it was not all muscle okay
there's no way there was a little bit of
dirty bulking going on there so I cannot
say that's the case I remember those
McDonald runs you know like I remember
you were like
but listen he had to cut weight and uh
it was not a it was not a long fight I
don't know if Jarvis is gonna fight
again I don't know if Sea Dog yesterday
we convinced Sea Dog to uh again uh but
slap again yeah slap slap again uh oh
and they're getting started so let's
tell you about their match uh we told
you about the event yeah after you talk
about all this you know uh it's the best
of two they play two rapid games
uh you know hopefully pending any
technical issues uh those are 10 minutes
and five second bonus per move and the
way you win is you have to win and draw
or you have to win two games and that's
how you win a best of two if it's one to
one we play a tie break and and the tie
break is a whole separate slide that we
don't need to talk about right it's it's
very convoluted but we're not even
bringing it up we trust one of them to
win yeah yeah we haven't had a tie break
yet we've been close but we've gotten
out of here uh within two games and
yesterday Sea Dog made quick work of
saikuno but he also was an
1176 Point favorite or something like
that like a 1076 points so yeah that's
like not his rating that's the margin
that he was better than the other yeah
yeah yeah although saikuno did over
perform uh Knight F3 Knight C6 on the
board and we're gonna get this
Sea Dog loves himself uh a little bit of
the uh Italian I mean they say study
your Classics you know the top Grand
Masters in the world but you seem to
have studied your Classics for POG
Champs you're you know these guys
repertoire
I just saw a Sea Dog play a game with
white yesterday in fact in fact he lost
his Pawn yesterday saikuno hit him with
the Petrov which I don't think either
knew that it was called that but that's
right uh you know then we had Knight
takes E4 uh do you think Sea Dog with
this with this 1148 is gonna go for a
little fried liver on Knight F6 I feel
like he might be at that rating where he
knows that it might not be you know a
killer move but even the nature of this
event POG Champs Knight G5 is a Pog
Champs move let me I'm just gonna go
ahead and say it well he he seems to
like the the Four Knights it's almost
like he's he's too good for his own good
if he was like not that good then he
would go Knight G5 right yeah you get
you start going up in level and you
start realizing like my angling Gambit
doesn't work well actually in your case
you drew a GM uh so it was uh that game
was a draw right or did you did you lose
that game it was uh it was a draw as in
I I earned a draw the final result was a
lot so but it was like 130 moves you
played it live at a time it was like 130
moves I sacked my queen in real life at
a real tournament against the GM a
serious Tournament game but it did
emerge with still zero points so you
know scoreboard don't lie scoreboard
don't lie but like enough time will go
by that I'll just keep saying it was a
draw and we'll just yeah if you keep
perpetuating that thank you yeah I I I
honestly thought it was a draw then as I
was saying it I was like maybe not in
any case like you you get to a level
that people start telling you you have
to stop playing gambits you have to stop
playing certain things because it's not
going to work uh Knight G5 now is no
longer really a cheese it's just a good
move because there's
no way to guard that
yeah now you're basically playing the
fried liver but you've got an extra
piece developed this is a fried liver on
steroids if he wants to go for it but
you know he's gonna oh I mean he's he's
playing great chess right he's taking
the center you can never fault people
for that
no absolutely not I like that he even
postponed castling interesting that he's
completely I don't know if it's
oblivious or you're right like maybe
he's just stopping himself because he's
like oh that never works but
um that's why black had to go here
because he would be able to Castle but
this is a fantastic move and
I'm still so stunned but this is also a
good move I'm I'm stunned
Jarvis is is basically an unrated player
that doesn't play chess I mean
yeah chats.com reading we have no idea
full question mark yep and from if you
just looked at this game almost like a
yes the ELO I know you've done quite a
few of those Levy but if you just looked
at this game there's no way that you
would make that gas based on the moves
and even the games that he played
yesterday yeah I I mean we have a little
bit to work with right which is the move
Pawn here and and and if we go back
developing the bishop is better than
blocking in your piece but I mean
the game is not won and lost in the
first four moves well for some of the
chat members it is but that's right
that's life but we'll see if Sea Dog
does something with this Pawn because
you're very tempted when the bishop
comes here to to deal with it but that
would be a huge mistake after takes
takes you would simply lose the pawn
whether you take with the pawn or the
queen so if he goes here or here
he's sharp and it's morning over there
in Japan so he should be
yeah I was gonna say it's um you know
for for someone like Jarvis who's quite
new he's actually left the tension so
the pawn went to D4 and he didn't
capture it I'm already impressed like
that's kind of just in itself an
advanced concept
yeah a lot of beginners go oh I could
take that right and like there's no
further thought it's just I could take
it and by the way Connor uh he did play
D5
so a sure sign of a beginner now would
be to venture out to the edge just
because you can uh this is what whoa
that wow I did not expect that
yeah and and I think the eval bar is
asleep because that is not
that that's not the best move there uh
Bishop takes I mean there's a different
eval bar for the POG Champs event I
thought they did chess.com not tell you
it's it's just always equal
yeah I I click the different Tab and now
analysis is on and yeah we see that
um
just a move ago it was actually even if
Jarvis had jumped into the center but he
was like the knight in the bishop are
worth the same the problem is the bishop
is no longer hanging oh
oof
this is the this is the thing he's got
that look on his feet he knows what he
did hands on the face
ouch oh it goes from bad to worse yeah
it was good he had to move the Knight
yeah he just miscalculated when he
played the move B5 he probably thought
he takes my knight I take his Bishop but
that's right then you gotta go well what
if he doesn't right what if he does
something differently
and uh and I feel like if this was guess
the ELO and you played guess the ELO
right after it pawned at D5 yep my guess
could be so astronomically wrong right
because the very next two moves you have
a maybe a a much different picture yeah
once you see B5 you kind of go like you
know up to D5 solid little 1200 chests
but he had to keep it simple he just had
to move his Knight
uh unfortunately it just went from bad
to worse and in the span of three moves
we've lost the pawn we've lost the
Knight and the most disrespectful thing
about this position is that I think you
know what I'm about to say oh tell them
love you tell them you shouldn't take
the queen apparently a queen to this
diagonal threatening a Checkmate is a
higher evaluation point
than taking the queen but naturally Sea
Dog takes the queen and what an absolute
amateur Levy I mean this just goes to
show what you know why he's out there
I mean obviously poke had some fun when
the eval bar actually legitimately does
recommend not taking the queen I guess
that's how good his position is
yeah let's take a look at a
Sea Dogs stream see how he's feeling
negative of how he plays we can't go
easy on our opponent we still need to
win we can still blunder the Lord knows
we've done it many a Time
um
oh let's play smart about this here
he's very respectful even in Victory
yeah that was a really cool set as well
he's like don't go easy and you know
we've definitely plundered before so
take your time and
let's look for an opening here by
expanding the poems is never a bad Shout
your main expansion with the Pawns
uh I'm also down to just try it yeah
because I
think it's worthwhile
great technique that's probably that
right there Levy is like one of the best
takeaways he said it so I don't even
have to really bring it up but when
you're ahead especially this much
material pretty much any equal value
pieces that you take off the board will
benefit you
yeah I mean black has four pieces right
so now he's got three he's got a bunch
of Pawns too but they they ain't scaring
anybody so very nice move I'm I think
his next move is going to be castling
he'll probably Castle because he's gonna
stay poisoned patient and at some point
he's either going to go for that pawn
expansion as he talked about or he's
going to realize how well his pieces
work together his Queen needs
really like no access I mean for example
nice question for beginners here is how
do you get your queen to B3 in two moves
and they're all going to be like I don't
know it's not possible you move your
knight right here we go here and by the
way I said he's
are definitely on the same page right
now yeah just castles and
it's tough for black I mean it really is
uh
probably launched some pawns get the
yeah but see now the bishop loses the
guard
well he the pawns have been launched we
can say that
yeah there they go yeah I think at this
point Levy I might already be putting my
eggs in the stalemate basket like I
might be calling it early and saying you
know what we're gonna jettison the rest
of the pieces take everything and I'm
already going for stalemate not even
like 15 moves into the
yes yes with black here you just got to
get rid of all these bones the problem
is you can't even move a couple of them
I mean that's not so bad when it comes
to stalemate but how do you get rid of
the outside pawns you just
fire them down the board and then and
then where's your king going right if
it's just operation stalemate oh this is
it's a lot tough yeah no you can't at
this point there's not really anything
Jarvis can do himself it's more like Sea
Dog has to mess this up with some of the
biggest blunders this event will ever
see
yes it would be far more impressive if
Sea Dog stalemated then if Jarvis got
stalemated right look left let's just
hand him the award right there but I I
am always uh of the belief and in this
tournament especially you just don't
resign Levy I don't care how painful it
is we've seen crazy happen
yeah yep uh right now by the way you
could just gobble one of the best things
to do once you start taking a few pawns
with the queen you can always sack it
for a rook in a perfect world you give
it up for both if you can take two but
uh
you know and I want that Zoom back you
see we just got like the eye of Sauron
like it just went right up to the camera
no no that was uh it just looked right
into his soul I didn't see I was looking
for the fastest Force stalemate on the
board
keep us updated with your findings there
yeah I unfortunately there's no uh
there's there's nothing mathematical
here I think he's just gonna eat a few
pawns and speak with a silky smooth
voice into his microphone about how you
can't take the opponent lightly I'm I'm
really looking forward to his third
matchup against Frank uh because that I
think will be a good challenge or or
maybe not maybe he's just very clearly
the favorite
for a while until he faces another 1000
or something like that
right but you know I have to say that
um Darvis just kind of imploded this
game so it started out so well for him
so you can tell he's got the
fundamentals like the foundation is
there but then just tactically speaking
and like maybe the value of the pieces
is not firmly established for him yet
that is true
um the good news is he's getting rid of
one of his mobile pawns there we go all
right so
the C Pawn can move so if he takes
and then neither of these pawns will go
anywhere yeah but he's
he's he's fighting but yeah I mean even
even this deep into the game Sea Dog
doesn't even take a pawn with check
right he just yeah
measured approach Rook D1 you know
well there we go there's an attack
there's a threat yep Levy you know uh
all you need is a chip and a chair
yeah
and if Queen here you lose the queen and
you're still completely winning with
white but
at least the other that's how good the
position is yeah you could lose your
queen and your knight and be winning you
could probably lose a queen in a rook
and be winning I don't know about both
Rooks but
yeah Queen comes back and okay I'm
getting aggro
yep I like it I like it I mean if black
is doing anything it's got to be on the
G file probably towards the king you
know like both Rooks slide to the G file
would be uh probably the only semblance
of a threat for the rest of the game I
would say yeah there's
one more semblance of a threat and it's
the fact that Sea Dog could just start
spectating his position for prolonged
periods of time that's right and run out
of time
mm-hmm
PS4 and a half minutes remaining I
I don't know
yeah and it's always a question like how
do these players handle true time
pressure like when the 30-second
remaining Panic starts to to set in
um because yeah you can really make some
moves that you didn't even know you were
capable of oh yeah or or the lag thereof
you just lose on time and you don't even
realize how that happened right this is
this is really wild there's two pawns
that Sea Dog can take
and he offers a third one for capture
this is maximum tension right here I
mean everything can take everything but
nobody's taking anybody
okay so I'm gonna go ahead I'm just
gonna ask the question okay he answered
it for me so that's good I was about to
say do we know that ons can capture
diagonally
yes because because I just haven't seen
it yet that's all I'm gonna say I
haven't seen it I'm gonna go back to B5
that B5 move definitely came out of
somewhere right I mean we definitely
know
but for some reason yeah they uh they
wanted to keep the tension there for a
minute the fastest way a lot of you are
seeing M16 or uh that that that's not
the British intelligence agency that
that is uh that is in fact a forced
Checkmate that can occur if you take
here because the king would have to come
out I don't think Sea Dog Sees it but
the good news is he doesn't have to
yeah he really he really doesn't he
might just find it accidentally
yeah like you know like take here some
Queen B3 to cut off the escape the
Checkmate might also not be a fourth
sequence of moves but rather just laying
a uh like a trap so the king can't
actually Escape but we'll uh we'll see
he seems to have a a pretty good grip on
the position though Sea Dog like he's
not uh you know vulnerist King's not
vulnerable to back rank a Checkmate
pieces are all kind of Defending when
another centralized so I think he's
converting this really well honestly
yeah I couldn't have said it better
myself this is this is very very good
technique
and it's tough when
it you get you get hit early
with with a with a tactic right or or
you make a mistake early I mean he's
just playing it so clean he's just
removing the pieces I mean we got the
big camera we got the zoom cam again
yeah I saw that something you saw it
this time right
yeah is he doing that are we doing that
who's doing that I think I think he
might be I like it though it's like it's
like when he's thinking he Zooms in on
himself yeah it's good very dramatic
Zach uh he could just take that by the
way he's got three pieces stacked up and
yeah black is left with his two most
difficult pawns to mobilize
so he can't get a stalemate it's not
that simple a stalemate here would be so
bad a badass for for black that would be
uh yep but look you know even if it
looks hopeless I will say and I I you
know I offer this advice to a lot of
people just move the pawns anyway you're
right you'll probably get mated but hey
at this point if you're black play
You're remaining two pawns and just move
them as far as they'll go because that's
your only hope of a draw
um is that you just run yourself out of
moves and then get your King still made
it so may as well
I have seen so many Noob games that that
a player just pushes this Pawn
intermittently oh and by the way he has
made a blunder King takes Rook that's
right
the pawn runs and then takes and becomes
a queen
this Pawn can't
this Pawn can you push it in a sneaky
way you know good oh and it's it's on
the board
here we go yeah three minutes as well so
the first uh sign that he's human you
know that's Sea Dog he bleeds like the
rest of us Sea Dog lost 10 points of
accuracy for the move Knight takes D6
he was firing at 88
nearly 89 and now he's down to 79 brutal
it's like he didn't submit one
assignment and your grade just goes down
10 percent
yeah that's it's a little unforgiving
but the thing is he's still so
completely winning as you highlighted
the entire White Queen could disappear
from the board and white might still be
winning I thought everybody could
disappear the Queen the night like maybe
not against The Rook but okay this is
given a big big giant orange question
mark by the analysis for that's crazy
you know what's so disrespectful to
Knight F5 like
well I said perfectly good move Levy
what what the hell is this nonsense well
I'm on you see Knight C4 is made in 34.
you understand oh and and 98 Knight E8
to cover a couple more squares and
threaten the Knight of six it's actually
made in 14. so yeah no understood yeah
yeah that's that's obvious now that you
mention it yeah and and and and well now
this is made in five oh the skewer
oh he won material she's total amateur
he missed the median five
brutal I'm I'm shocked that one didn't
get a question mark
clean very nice yeah yeah Knight F5 was
only plus 47 according to this move
those pawns move those pawns A5 H5 this
is your moment because I think that Sea
Dog is uh not going to be able to like
oh there's a there's some mates
potentially coming but I was gonna say
with the king in the middle Levy it is
hard to just like generate a Checkmate
so
give those pawns up
yeah and and sea dog is making a very
common Mistake by the way if he takes
that other Pawn okay he's not taking the
pawn anymore he's gonna try to get a
ladder you you want to get to a
situation where you can laterally cut
off the king and you don't want the king
to get tangled in between your pieces
so there we see that oh oh that's very
nice nice
good stuff oh another way is the
flicking H4 by the way yeah I like what
he's doing you gotta give Jarvis some
credit here he's uh being as tricky as
possible
yeah unfortunately his Pawn still has a
legal move but he could get checked in
front of the ball oh
let's see from his perspective
[Music]
let's create the ladder boys
oh he knows about the ladder he's
climbing the rungs
Yeah clean
oh
oh he moved three moves and everything
and yet with the Queens it's vicious
[Music]
smooth GG so smooth really well played
wow one big up there
it's not even unless there's a blunder
that sounds like the chess.com you know
review at the end of the game I think
it's written exactly like that that was
a big up though my party yeah yeah
that's what it it tells you verbatim it
was a big
um it says that exact thing yes yes I
don't know if we're allowed to curse but
they can curse you know yeah that's
right we might get in trouble uh after
one
it's Sea Dog leading one to nothing
undefeated thus far in uh in podchamps
five nothing too crazy uh he has played
three games and he's won them all
actually a lot of players are undefeated
they just also haven't played a game but
a good start for him uh were you
impressed
by his technique yeah like it it really
has to be said that okay you might be a
favorite in your match your opponent
might blunder but even still the the
fact is the only real mistake that I saw
was him dropping his roof otherwise he
was tactically sharp he took every piece
of material he seemed to keep all his
pieces defended nice and safe it was
never in doubt even his mistake never
put the game in doubt so it was a really
clean Victory start to finish and that's
a hard thing to do in chess is to just
have a game where honestly the result
never seemed in doubt
right on the flip side
he was given it after move 405 with the
move B5 like that some blunders are not
the same as others sometimes you make
some sort of mistake and it's
it's not nothing special but sometimes
yeah it could be really really bad and
in that case it was uh and we have uh
we've got game two coming up so they're
going to flip colors Jarvis is going to
play with the white pieces and Sea Dog
will be black and all he has to do is
not lose he can make a draw in this game
and he will be 2-0 in the group stage
yeah maybe we'll see some gamesmanship
he might start the game and offer a draw
can you even do that I I really I wonder
if you can uh we I think we're checking
in on him seeing what opening he's going
to choose
it's a draw button do it Sea Dog
maybe maybe not there I thought maybe we
were going to uh to hear his audio but
we can't give it away you know these are
important thoughts yes it's it's early
in the game and you know the thought I
had yesterday was it is Jarvis playing a
Vienna or is he just developing Knights
like this this was my big question
does he know the Vienna opening you know
what let's I think my boy Jarvis to
benefit the doubt here absolutely he
knows Viviana lovey all right don't down
to him for a second this is the Vienna
Jarvis variation I mean maybe he was
going for you know those Sicilians with
with with Knight C3 and Bishop B5
yeah it's a fun one it's a fun Sicilian
well maybe he's doing that but just you
know against E5 that's my biggest thing
I accidentally turned on auto play there
we go
we get to relive this important opening
moment
Jarvis is definitely solid in the
opening he he just needs to not use the
flanks right like he he's got to be more
Center oriented uh he's got he's got to
build good habits if you will
um
man after my heart that's right build
good habits which means like nights out
so for example Knight F3 would be super
common move the other thing that I
usually recommend
um when you're just like kind of unsure
at the beginning is just if there's
something that you can take and it's
equal value keep it simple and take it
so like Bishop takes Knight would be a
nice normal move here as well
um and yeah getting castled as soon as
possible is another really good opening
habits your King's not in the middle
remember last game Levy it was his King
in the middle of the board which was one
of the reasons he lost so many uh
material points yeah he played D3 He
never castled and then he played B4 uh
and yeah just in general a move like
Punta B4 here just the first thing that
has to go through your head is and and
some beginners just don't even they
don't realize this when you were
attacking certain pieces the piece can
see you too uh
each other
that's right
not not like a sniper uh oh like from
the other side of the board you mean
yeah I mean like it's not a situation
where it's like a sniper who's like
looking at a Target and the target can't
see snipers it's not like that it's like
you're looking at each other dead in the
eyes after the move B4 so it's a little
awkward
like for example the pawn on F2 right
now is just enjoying life but the bishop
there is perched on a Mountaintop going
I will destroy you like given any
opportunity and yet this is just this is
a bit disrespectful from Sea Dog yeah
this is uh I mean I'd like to see Jarvis
I have a feeling like you might just go
for the move uh E3 but Knight D5 Levy
just heading into the middle of the
board attacking that Queen would be a
nice punishment
um for Sea Dogs I would say you know
overzealous Queen F6 no castles you
ain't never getting mated now the pawn
on F2 despite not seeing the bishop on
C5 is very well fortified uh but by the
way little danger levels Knight D5 the
bishop is worth much less than the queen
but I I do think that Jarvis is going to
take the knight uh although it it also
is a very common beginner thing to be
like why did I actually go out there and
then just come back yeah that's right
not realizing could have just gone there
in the first place so you know we did
here to maybe take but
at taking
um you know it sounds like an obvious
concept but
um after you take something it's your
turn again which is a nice thing to
remember so he takes and now actually
with Queen takes back Levy you're
highlighting maybe uh some Tic Tacs
yeah okay D4 is is not a bad move but
Knight takes Pawn Knight takes Pawn
always a common blind spot for beginners
I mean uh Sea Dog himself made a mistake
yesterday in his game against saikuno he
he lost the pawn in the center like on
the on the first or second move but
there's nothing wrong with D4 I mean no
I don't hate it oh it's a good you'll
notice guys that the eval bar is
actually still uh in White's favor so
this move is a good move it's just it
missed an opportunity to have an
overwhelming event
let's check in on Jarvis uh he I he does
not stream his games I don't think
although he might be today uh I'm I'm
not sure actually but let's see what
he's got to say if anything
he's focused right yeah he is focused
Bishop moves back
Ah that's good for me right
hell yeah oh sorry I don't know yeah I
felt like he's speaking to me too uh
let's not make a blunder here
because obviously I can push this Pawn
up
and it attacks the it moves the queen
away which seems good
this seems good right can't hate on this
because you know this logic is I like it
like he he's making sense he's not
getting credit from that computer here
but
he's making sense to me
yeah he's not unfortunately getting
credit because it's considering it a
Miss it's giving it a big red X but red
X doesn't mean bad it's not like in
Family Feud it just means you had
something better and your position is
full potentially it could be bad but in
this case it's not he could have taken
the the pawn that's what he could have
done uh but now the pawn no longer
attacks the pawn and the Knight can
attack the pawn but the queen
Confederate none of that really matters
because Sea Dog just hates this Pawn he
hates it yeah no it's been hanging
almost you know last what four moves or
so yeah
um and yeah you could you could see as
soon as he played Queen takes C6 he was
giving up that pawn he didn't care
oh and it's been taken by the way and
now Cedar could accidentally hang a
queen I mean there are mine squares all
over here
very easy to do
Queen F6 is a square he's been to before
so he might remember it as like a
familiar safe spot
um and it wouldn't be a bad move so from
his perspective I think that's
hopefully uh where he's gonna land on
yeah and there it is yeah now
very difficult psychologically but
sometimes going back to the exact same
score you came from is the best move but
listen as long as Jarvis doesn't make a
forward night move
he's fine literally any retreating night
move is good
now that's you boldly assuming that he's
gonna move his Knight there there are
there's a world of options in front of
uh Jarvis here Han Bishop Queen yeah
lots and lots of opportunities to play a
good move but also to blunder
yeah yeah yeah I'm terrified I he might
go Bishop here and defend the Knight but
lose the bishop that's honestly that's
kind of what I was thinking because it
develops another piece and defends the
current one so it feels like a good move
but uh you're right yeah it does hang a
bishop somehow that feels
on a jinx
you know what he did last game he he saw
the night hanging and then he was like
I'm gonna counter-attack he might go D6
I really hope he learned from the last
game and
oh
there it is okay defense now you know
another big test here will be the move
Pawn to D6 because as you mentioned it's
tough to ring the Knight back to let's
say the square you just moved it from it
just came from F3 you might feel like oh
that's a waste of time or like I don't
want to do that
um he's gonna have to notice this pin
Levy yeah can we I'd really like to
check in on his thought process uh
before he makes a move he might be
really like upset here because he he
thinks he's an underdog Jarvis uh and uh
Jarvis might also just be defeated at
this point mentally like oh I'm uh I
messed up and then he's just gonna make
a move and lose something so
um
I would love to check in on him
yeah I don't know if he's still talking
concerned at the moment uh I think that
we're chilling it's one Pawn down it's
not great I'm gonna have a pretty rough
position because I get out of it
and
bringing my queen out early was a
mistake it was the exact kind of mistake
I thought it would be
and he's really laying into it however
he's taking longer to take his turns
like this is terrified that's why my ear
I mean he's got to move this right
this is such a critical move Levy oh my
gosh yeah
wow super impressive
he played Knight F3
um
well done
yeah you got a hand that is not an easy
move backwards knight move and the only
one on the board
um with that night that was sufficient
yeah trade of Queens would be good he is
up one Pawn here so hopefully Jarvis
starts to realize like wait a minute it
might be the underdog against this guy
but look at the board just count him up
I got one extra so I have to be ahead
hopefully that gives him some confidence
whoa
this is a wild game it's just a huge
immediate question mark like uh Buzz
but uh but but the reason for that is
because of all pass on now uh I've
wanted to check in on Jarvis to see not
not Sea Dog to see if he yeah he does it
we don't even have to wow
that is impressive oh look at The
Confident sip as well that's the first
on person in uh in pogchamps five right
there now that's a hype moment right
there
that he didn't even hesitate he spent
like almost no time on that move look at
that and that was the best move
well it is forced you know after all so
but they don't know that right and so I
just figured that he didn't but proven
wrong and happy to be
by Jarvis
all right we're now going to check in on
Jarvis see how he's going to make
progress in the position
feel like this queen trade needs to
happen or else I'm going to do something
stupid
because if I uh if I push here
and then he takes it with the pawn
he's looking at E5
is this a dumb move
let's find out
Levy I like the thought process from
Jarvis it might be like a really big
here and then I take with processed
yeah I I like it too but I thought he
started that thought with I have to
trade queens or I'm gonna do something
stupid
is that what he said he said he didn't
yeah he's like I have to get this queen
trade or I might do something stupid and
then he said what about this other move
he said yeah it could be a huge blunder
and he said let's find out full send but
that's yeah that is how you have to play
I would never recommend and
there's a lot of things going on right
now C5 to try to attack here is just
ridiculous I mean black is in no
position to call the shots right he's
he hasn't moved five of the seven pieces
from their starting squares
yeah that's a great point when you when
you think about like oh what a great
moves well
I mean D5 he's castle like this is a
model game from Jarvis and I think the
position is going to start to catch up
the Sea Dog he can't keep just making
these one move attacks on the queen and
expect that Jarvis is just gonna blunder
yeah oh speaking of which
you literally just said that he can't
keep making these one move attacks he's
he's completely missed the Rook no he's
he's completely blindsided like Levy
he's just on a mission to attack that
Queen this is Jarvis's moment wrap up
this game if he takes that Rook he just
played the queen up and he's done it
nice move
wow
incredible stuff and it's nearly made
it's nearly made he's lucky it's not
actually and he gets out of it with
bishop d8 and make sure Jarvis you know
pay attention that Knight on E5 is
hanging don't get ahead of yourself he's
played great game so far and he put it
away
so tough here right because you've got
two modes now with white chop all the
pieces off the board what is he reading
right now
is we need a close-up or something what
what does that say he's played by the
way by the way he just played the bus
move again now if you take the Knight
it's mate because the queen doesn't
guard the bishop
oh the book is it's called beat
depression now
that's the title of the book
he just pulled out beat depression now
started reading it and honestly after
Rook D1 you might have to read a little
faster
oh my goodness by the way why does he
have that book so close to him I hope
he's doing all right doesn't he reading
it anyway I see dog listen if you ever
need any any of you watching this right
now I was there you know just you just
gotta reach out this is tough you know
we we understand by the way yeah this is
one of the worst activities to do if
you're if you're suffering from I mean
my business it's it'll just get you more
Rook D1 is ridiculous and the worst part
of this is Knight to E7 trying to Castle
checkmates you even faster so oh my God
Sea Dog has to go here but he is
completely lost wow and he's played it
that's a fantastic move from Sea Dog
um he's definitely you know nearly dead
to rights here but he is keeping the
game going and Jarvis so far has I mean
really he's had a few misses Levy but
he's had no big mistakes no blunders
this is a this is a great great game
from Jarvis but so hard to play a full
game with no mistake that's exactly
right and before he had played Rook D1
which was just insane and and we see we
see Sea Dog just
he's reading up yeah we can't even see
his face anymore I mean he's just
he's playing a different game right how
do we know there's no chess moves in
there isn't this a fair play violation
which would ever let a Grandmaster read
a book on stream I mean on a event how
do we know there's no chess books in
that book
honestly Knight D5 was just played there
could be chess moves in that book and I
still think Jarvis would uh be making a
making a push here
yeah we've got to bring the board back
because Jarvis got a little bit
I mean his self yeah and now now Queen
takes Knight is a clean night the
advantage has halved from 14 to seven
make no mistake seven is seven is uh
that's a good number yeah it's a good
number uh solid number
but but after that it's going to be a
struggle and he needed to play Queen C6
track there was a couple of lines here
where Black's King could have gotten
checkmated like on the d8 Square for
example because the pin right there was
so good advice for beginners is in a
position like this hump the king don't
hunt the queen hunt the king
try to make the king uncomfortable uh
but will Sea Dog find 95 or is he too
busy uh
doing his uh is he still reading yeah
exactly always found it and Amman I'm
really worried because Knight C7 is a
very natural follow-up to that move and
you might just lose both nights that's
right
um
talking about the world of reasonable
moves here Bishop from C1 either
capturing the Knight or moving out to F4
looked like some pretty nice options for
Jarvis the other reason I like bringing
that Bishop out is I'm a little scared
if that Rook on D1 has to move for some
reason maybe to recapture on D5 if you
get back rank made it so I'm I'm holding
my breath he doesn't get like Queen E1
Checkmate oh that's so brutal you're
right okay but F4 is a nice move I don't
hate this move the top computer move
here is to give the queen away
oh my god do you realize yf4 is so
strong no I don't have to ask you I'm
just it's because no I I actually need
the explanation all right well let's do
it uh it's because the queen can't
actually guard the bishop on d8 anymore
it's unbelievable so anywhere the queen
moves
it could be lost
Queen F5 there's like various discovered
attacks for example Knight I guess
Knight E3 there is back to F6 so you
would have to play Queen C6 first yeah
Queen F5 is the best but for example
Queen E4 the Discover check and you win
the queen that's I mean
and one tough move might be Queen down
to E2 but it looks like Queen E2 maybe
Knight C3 kind of insane
oh that's typical Jarvis move yeah he's
probably already worked it out well we
see Queen F5 yeah I
Queen C6 now would be fantastic that
could actually end the game pretty
quickly
but if Jarvis finds something else I
mean I don't know the the the worst
thing that could happen here is uh is
black castling although then there's a
nice little Queen takes d8 for the boys
oh yeah that's Jarvis is thinking about
that one right now Levy yep you're
calling it exactly as he would play
it'll pick the queen up you know nice
little nice little end game transition
here you know we're just gonna clear all
the pieces off and you know win oh this
is trademark Jarvis yeah Jarvis nice and
quietly oh he's played Knight C7 does he
realize how good it is
or
is this potentially going to get him in
more trouble than not because you know
what I mean this could be good but it
couldn't be bad it is a great move
though yep
I know what you mean I don't know if he
saw that he was he was pinning there and
and he was in good shape he might just
start taking all the pieces but if he
gets his Bishop off the back rank I I
don't know I
I don't know how he's going to lose but
it will probably be at the hands of some
discover check
because now also
um we're starting to get to that
territory where the the time is a real
it's almost like a piece it's almost
like the the clock is on the board
because it matters you could be down
material the way that Sea Dog is but
stay up on time and just the pressure of
having to play quickly is certainly
worth some amount of material
absolutely right oh yeah wow they're
both oh my goodness that's actually a
genius move because if you take the
Knight he's gonna lose the Rook but then
then Sea Dogs getting the pieces over
here and I don't like that anymore yeah
that's what you know what Sea Dog might
be too good for his own good I mentioned
it before Bishop takes Knight drops The
Rook which it looks like a blunder so he
might not do it for that reason
that's absolutely right Bishop Bishop
takes uh is is unironically the top
computer move too to try to launch an
immediate counter play but you're right
so you don't like oh I can't do that
right but
first of all Jarvis says to see that and
second of all that's actually still the
best move
so you're saying we're like five steps
ahead of these guys and they might not
even play the first move of our
variation got it so we're five steps
ahead but they're five steps ahead of
where we are also like it's crazy yeah
that's right you know because then
there's that yeah by the way they both
have a minute and 40 seconds but in 30
seconds so this is gonna be a chaotic
finish and credit to Jarvis for holding
his nerves together
because last game was was not like this
no and he could have easily just been
like oh you know I got crushed first
game because he really did get crushed
in the first game but that's the way
chess is sometimes an early blunder just
sets you up for immediate failure and
it's just not representative of your
skills so I'm glad we got a game where
obviously Jarvis is shining so far but
he's still got a long way to go
absolutely right Jarvis is shaking his
head by the way which is funny because
he's completely winning if only players
could play a chess game with the eval
bar there oh my goodness uh
please don't take the pun this is how
this game could actually end right now
that would be even more fatal than last
game among oh that could be a really
epic finish and it's already got me
wondering it's such a likely move Bishop
E3 you wonder was he just developing or
was he targeting the C5 Pawn when he
played that mode that's exactly right
all right let's see what Jarvis is
thinking about
I love this featured chat Jarvis just
needs to trade pieces and reduce counter
play yeah well thanks Chad why does it
just go and win yeah yeah yeah and and
speaking of which he defended his Bishop
what did he just take I just oh that's
the bishop yeah
um so is there any reason I don't do
this
because
wow on the board
this is crazy can we bring it back to a
full screen oh oh Sea Dog has lost the
night Sea Dog has lost the Knight
uh excuse me not the Knight the queen
Knight D5 is is is a check you can't
take it because of the pin it wins the
queen but it's the only winning move I'm
on because otherwise he loses all of
this
this is crazy it's it's almost like you
have like the Fatal blow in front of you
yeah but not played and it's gonna flip
around
oh
oh nice Knight 95 was so tough to play
like a backwards night move
while your Rook is hanging
yep yep yep and by the way this is why
we do puzzles literally just so your
brain is like where's the check oh
that's a check but it's very hard to do
all of that with that little time on the
clock but he's bringing his Rook this is
still anybody's game uh the computer
wants to play Queen takes H2 and Bishop
C7 check and win the the queen because
of the Discover check if Sea Dog does
that I don't even I mean I'll count down
if he plays Queen HD 100 gifted Subs to
see dog if he plays Queen H2 I will lose
it
I mean I'll split it with you
ain't no way man I think he's gonna play
like Bishop G4 or something which which
by the way could lose after rookie three
but uh okay rookie yeah I was gonna say
rookie eight and he's almost going King
f8 and it's like if you saw the
beginning of this game and then the end
of this game you would have no idea that
black did not Castle
absolutely right it would just look like
a completely normal game yeah between
two people uh 32 seconds 22 seconds this
might be the first game of pot Champs
that's decided on the clock it's minus
four but it's only minus four because
two Bishops are better than the rook and
computer is prepared for the end game
this is not a minus four position I'm on
like at all oh not at all Queen H7 I
thought he set that up too he brought
the queen back to the middle it's almost
like he anticipated this and he did what
a play oh my goodness and and and and
and now apparently Rook E3 is holding
the balance don't even I don't even know
why that's the best move Queen h8 makes
sense now Bishop G8 wow played
immediately
oh my goodness this is terrifying you
know the books the Rooks operate really
well when they're together so I wouldn't
mind seeing Jarvis go Rook from the D
file to the f file or Rook from the file
to the D file just bring them together I
think just bring them together get them
off the same diagonal with the color
right like the Bishops here this is a
ridiculous position 20 seconds each
every move they get they get five
seconds bonus Tyler didn't know that
yesterday if you thought low time oh oh
Queen's eggs
but I don't know if he sees that big
swing but he's got to take the queen you
might think that because his opponent's
offering it he shouldn't take it three
seconds two seconds he's gonna make a
move he's gonna lose on time he's gonna
lose some time and driver's license oh
my God
Jarvis make a move he's got to make a
movie
insane how is he playing so well this is
the best moves have been with one second
that's unbelievable he's up to 10
seconds he is completely winning just
take the pawn he will never get mated
oh my God how did he flip this around
Rook D3 is fine in fact it's great Levy
Brook E3 yeah I I don't even I think he
just clicked the square rookie three if
he plays this is just unbelievable he's
oh my oh God my God
this is insane this is a master class
this is the most clutch man alive if he
gets this Rook on a dark Square it's
game over Rook A3 King F2 just don't
lose the Rook put the Rook on a dark
Square this is unusable Jarvis
R square it's attacked so he knows he
has to move it at least yep and if the
king gets closer kick the king out and
and and just gather your nerves the only
way he loses this game is losing The
Rook on a diagonal if he puts a rook
behind the bishop yep now the pawns
actually did even up there so don't
forget this game is still ongoing
you know Sea Dog has done a good job to
stabilize yup Bishop to beef oh but he's
lost a pawn oh that's that's huge for
Jarvis and and Jarvis gets it now he
gets it oh Rook at four Rook at four oh
that's insane wow
who is this man oh my god oh and he
takes the bishop this is unbelievable
the only way he throws this is with the
pawn if C3 on the board he's got to take
Levy where to chess.com find this guy
raving n a yeah okay nice joke this is
like how players showed up in the in the
old days and had no elos he's got to go
for the other Pawn oh okay bring the
king to guard the pawn bring the king
Jarvis Jarvis oh I don't like where this
is headed I'm on okay wrong direction
I he's panicking we're also wrong
direction because he can't make a pass
Pawn Levy yeah this is real bad he's got
he's got to create the oh my God oh my
God oh my God no no no he stopped upon
stop the Pawn With The Rook stop the
pawn Jarvis he's got to stop the pawn if
he plays King D1 he's gonna do the king
first oh please no he's doing it he's
doing it well King D2 King D2 stops the
pawn
he's still winning oh my goodness
oh you know what's gonna happen Levy
after H4 he's gonna push the pawn you
really shouldn't oh no he's gonna push
the pawn oh you're so right
don't do it he still hasn't thrown the
game completely but at this point I I
expect that he's gonna be trigger-happy
to push that next Pawn yes and you have
to lead with the king in King and pawn
end games if the king and the pawn are
together on the same line with the King
defending it's a draw you have to lead
with it is like an escort yeah high end
by the way uh but if he put if he plays
like this it's it's just
he might actually win wait a minute G5
G5 come on Jarvis
for all the people here watching for all
the fans King you have to with the King
I'm on he's gonna die he's gonna be
forced into a win King E6 G6 King F6
King H6
oh my God
oh my God Jarvis is done at the Red
Carpet for the queen for the queen it's
on the board Levy he now has to take a
breather he's I got a minute and a half
so much time take your time Jarvis and
show us this Checkmate do you think he
knows it
oh my God you need to know night
opposition and you need to know he
doesn't know night opposition he's going
to do this in a very strategic way he's
going to do it he's going to do his best
but God has so much time I'm not even
sure he realizes how much time he's
built up with those five seconds every
move he's fully in panic mode like me in
title Tuesday versus 3000 except his
3000 is named Sea Dog VA and we are
currently witnessing one of the most
insane matches in POG Champs guys I mean
I I am on team Jarvis for this Checkmate
right now this is God he's got it but
I'm more I'm worried he's keeping the
wrong distance and you know when the
king gets to the edge he there is that
famous stalemate
everyone take a breather he's got to
bring the queen he's gotta bring the
queen cut the board off
cut the board off okay good progress now
the King has no access to about 45
squares or so
he's gonna bring the king I think
this is stalemate technique though yeah
this is stalemate technique exactly oh
this is
oh no
oh it's gonna be Queen C5 King C6 oh got
a bad feeling what a good move ninja
star play Queen before Queen before and
the game is over Queen before if he
finds it but he's gonna try to box it
with
a little bit Levy no King A7 Queen check
no no don't do it
it's made it's made it's made he's got
it anything
or that yeah like I said anything
anything
no closer
you did it
though we go to the reaction from Jarvis
God I mean this guy is fighting not to
be celebrating out loud right now
I'm hype let it be known
it was a party going on inside that
house yeah yeah Jarvis is calm let it be
known I will celebrate for this man he
just defeated the breed tournament
favorite the 1200 rated player after not
playing chess for two decades this is
unbelievable stuff
Jarvis Johnson what that that's like a
superhero name yeah yeah seriously this
dude I I think they gotta make a movie
about him when this is all over
this is insane
one to one with group Jarvis defeating
Sea Dog VA I mean
Levy this this is just insane what we
just witnessed I can't think of a better
way for the crowd to be entertained
they'd had ups and downs we thought he
was going to lose remember like Sea Dog
took all that material back and we said
okay he's probably lost it and then with
one second on the clock Levy he turned
in to a literal superhero and got it
done that was unbelievable he made a
move with probably the best move with
0.5 seconds on the clock and then played
the follow-up with one second on the
clock got his time all the way back up
to 90 seconds lost The Rook nearly threw
the end game and then just he clutched
the end game it was unbelievable now the
best part is this is our first tie break
apart James five so let's explain to
everybody how this is played um
including us yes I I'm finding out this
for the first time so it's a three
minute game with five seconds per move
we make it faster for time purposes now
the player playing white is determined
by the Caps the accuracy of the previous
two games and they play one game if it's
a tie they just switch colors they play
Until somebody wins and I have massive
news Jarvis gets white because his
accuracy was higher he outperformed not
only did he defeat
formed the highest rated player in the
tournament over the course of this
matchup so he gets white and I got more
news for you he just won with white so
Tony that's a lot to digest I'm thinking
in my head
man how the heck did he do that but he's
got the white pieces he's looking to
just run it back Levy yeah and we've got
five seconds until launch they now have
to speed this up because they get three
minutes for this game do we just remove
seven minutes from their clock this is
crazy this is absolutely nuts and here
we go
goodness strap in ladies and gentlemen
because uh we got another game Jarvis is
running it back with the white pieces
honestly Levy at this point he's
probably like okay I'll just play the
exact same moves you play the exact same
moves good with me good with me okay
yeah I mean he's just gonna play E4 and
move his Knights the the Sea Dog knows
his move
he might have maybe expected like a
little break
um something like that no there he is
okay E5 and and and I got news for you
the every second off of Sea Dogs clock
is turning this game more and more into
a coin flip I mean he is a favorite he
has a lot more experience and he did
just lose a game so you know recency
bias might sway you to think that Jarvis
is is the favorite here but uh Jarvis
has a 556 rating but I don't think he's
ever played a Blitz game on chess.com
against the human being so yeah and
we're we're now diving in to what could
be his literal first Blitz game and and
if he wins this that's just an insane
comeback down 1-0 to the the favorite
the group the tourney favorite man
I I don't even know what to say I I am
literally speechless and I and I have to
speak because this is a paid commentary
uh gig but uh I don't like I don't like
that Jarvis is already spending 30
seconds right this is the struggle to
speed things up because you have seven
less minutes but I don't hate that move
yep look at that Sea Dog is I don't know
if he really likes the move d4 or if
he's just bumping himself up in general
I think
yes both of these guys are just doing
whatever they want like it's kind of
funny Jarvis just in the zone Sea Dog
reading a book and
this feels like you know when when you
think about the types of chess players
that there are in the world I feel like
these two personalities are them like
there's there's the really internal just
you know measure trying to think about
your own moves in your own head Jarvis
and then there's Sea Dog who's totally
visible you know you can read everything
on his face
listen he's a performer he's an
Entertainer he's a semi-professional
cyclist at this point uh
and I I like that he's not so stressed
right because you might think
pre-tournament favorites stress you you
know you lose a game but uh no just two
minutes 22 seconds per player
it's it's an equal position this is
literally anybody's game one more small
update for the chat remember if you win
a matchup you get three points and a
loser gets zero not if it goes to a tie
break it goes to a tie break the loser
of the tie break gets some bonus and
gets one point while the winner gets two
so you're not gonna have a three point
winner uh and uh Bishop to D7 on the
board you should probably just take it
in Castle I mean this is unbelievable
from Jarvis yeah he's got himself a
solid opening so far remember that
blacks most likely move next is probably
Knight to F6 so the number one thing you
don't want is to drop that Center Pawn
so if he guards that he's good
it's incredible that move group B1 is an
over 1000 level move it's like oh it's
like a 1200 move easily yeah putting the
Rook on a semi-open file is just that's
just good chess
and yeah you know some people just say
oh it's such an easy move okay C4 is now
regressing a little bit right we want a
castle we want to build some we do but
you know Jarvis is an advanced player he
saw Queen A4 working the epon and the A2
Pawn so he had there was something there
Levy so he played C4 so Queen D3 is
absurd these are good moves these are
good moves like they're coming they're
coming slowly honestly it's a little
unfair that the engine is kind of
against them because Queen to G4 right
now is a really strong move and found by
Sea Dog that's why he's the fave yes
this is why he's the favorite oh my
goodness he is removing
he is removing the doubt that is you
gotta check the e-pawn you got a castle
here but he might not realize castling
can can be a oh oh what am I saying this
is Jarvis Johnson you don't know who
you're talking to Levy I said talking to
or about by the way and now Sea Dog has
to take this by the way he's found he's
not okay 95 de5 Pawn so F3 if Jarvis
plays that I'm I'm leaving no we're
we're done at that point these guys can
commentate
I'm on there's another way H3 Queen G6
Knight H4
that's a little more natural at the very
least H3 as a starting move it's just a
good good looking move I like that
yeah actually the computer claims that
line is equal after
it's probably gonna be something like F5
at the end yeah yeah exactly Queen here
Knight here the queen now cannot
geometrically defend the Knight that's
going to be a massive psychological blow
for Sea Dog if he finds Knight H4 we got
something else on our hands here because
oh Jarvis is absolutely killing it with
these moves even H3 Levy to force Sea
Dog to play this next move is already an
issue that he's posing oh he's lost a
knight
Jarvis is winning he's winning oh my God
what a blender
this is this is the greatest pogchamp
story of all time Knight to G5 just do
it
send it in
I'm speechless and the crazy Rook to B3
oh my god oh sure surely
surely not H6 H6 Queen H7 exactly as you
highlight H6 looks like it's kicking the
night away
the oh my God he's playing like a
monster right now this is unbelievable
because identity five Queen H4 he can
renew that mating threat and if Pawn
goes to H6 now after Queen H4 then I can
go to E6 yup the move F5 solved the
problem but created a massive long-term
problem on the E6 Square oh my God he's
played it he's played the best move
again and as long as he doesn't go back
but I don't even care I don't even care
if he goes back I would still be okay
now
I I will say if the Knight goes back to
F3 after H6
a Sea Dog might be in a in a good spot
yeah so we'll see the forward knight
move would be so strong
and he probably has the setting enabled
where he clicks the piece and sees the
available squares and he's gonna go I
can't do that I can't do that so let me
go Knight E6 and it's seven eight times
out of ten out of ten going forward is
the right move for most players like at
most levels of the game 96 is the best
move
what's he gonna do and honestly if he
plays Knight F3 as you mentioned still
you know all all good for him as long as
he saves the night he's in a good spot I
don't like how he has 25 seconds he's
gone back it's fine yeah he's gone back
but still look at that time now it's
gonna be
very very crucial yeah F4 sealing out
this position the very difficult thing
here for Jarvis the position is very
closed and he doesn't have a lot of time
and he's probably nervous although I
can't speak for him that man's been in a
boxing ring I I still think Sea Dog is
the favorite here because of the time
situation unless Yang's Queen
What A Move Young G4 so so strong I was
gonna say that Queen 9h4 was on a funny
looking Square he's offering a queen
trade when he's ahead of full piece
beautiful fantastic move fantastic move
and I trust him not to lose on time last
game he he got really he reminded us
he got real close but and now Sea Dog
under a minute
wow and let's not forget while Jarvis
was playing low on time last game so is
Sea Dog these guys were trading blows
and we might see that again another 20
second versus 20 seconds scramble Fest
totally nuts just okay Knight F5 is a
good move for now but you can't move the
Knight anymore uh Jarvis just has to
make any move and that's not easy maybe
he'll play Knight H4 again
or if he played the last game I don't
remember he played Knight G5 rookie won
anything just move something don't lose
on time yeah make a move
he doesn't have tactics remember last
game at least he had tactical moves to
find but here Rook F6 and he's gonna be
with another really tough decision yep
Rook F6 and he has to go back
which is fine you know he'll make a move
quickly yep now he's got to go backwards
don't hang the queen you gotta realize
that though yep four three he's gotta
make a move he's got to make a move
Jarvis oh my god oh he's living on the
edge 0.9
my heart rate
upon to G6 and he's gotta go here and
then H5 and he's gonna go forward he's
just gotta make a move he's gonna run
out of time the position is with the
bishop the bishop hasn't moved one he
he's lost oh he's lost on time
he's lost on time oh he lost on time
you can tell by that reaction One on
time
damn that three minutes is tough huh
blonda yeah I know
I know I'm not happy with how I played
today I play like ass
yeah I I was just giving up
after
three games of action
it is Sea Dog VA the top dog if you will
winning two to one
on tie breaks
to win our first match of the day
so unpredictable like 2-1 as a score
already indicates it's been an insane
match because it means we even had to go
the tie breaks to settle something that
alone would probably surprise anyone
that maybe just tuned in at which point
by the way you just missed an insane map
yeah that was Sensational Jarvis just
took the Undisputed number one ranked
player in the tournament to the absolute
Brink
to the absolute Brink and
and nearly beat him twice I I mean you
really cannot ask for more than that
what more to say I I really I I don't
know uh let's show you the group
standings for uh for group a uh if we
have them uh sea dog is still on top
but uh I believe with just maybe I just
got I just got word uh no no group
standings Levy we don't we don't want to
show those just yet uh yeah so no group
standings yeah all right I I got my half
co-host and uh half uh have uh half
production as well but Sea Dog is up top
but this group is wide open I mean
Jarvis is now the sleeper candidate to
win the consolation bracket uh my
friends we're going to take a very short
break uh when we return we will either
have an interview with the players and
if we're not able to get that we uh
we'll start the second and actually
final match of the day don't go anywhere
thank you
so potentially be stalemate but no
Ludwig has no mercy literally 50 wait oh
there was increment I didn't realize
there was increment yes there's a two
second increments of three minute plus
two seconds increment he has now
collected a lot of time went all the way
upcoming minutes
come on
[Music]
the timebreaker yes yes
move over mittens there's a new Top Dog
in town
Benji the bernadoodle might be an
international master of fetch but chess
lessons with his dad Gotham chess aren't
really sticking
host of his own Public Access TV show
wish boy knows a thing or two about the
most dramatic moment in chess history
a baller through and through buddy
buckets is moving his game from the
basketball court to the chessboard watch
out
pinky practices chess from the inside of
his mom's handbag on wolfstock's law
campus don't judge a dog by its Diamante
caller
honchick learned chess from his dad GM
Lavon aronian he has never lost to
another dog at chess and certainly won't
lose to you
this July the possumness is Unleashed on
chess.com
and fausty wow eats the two pieces with
the Rook Aaron made a huge investment
giving up his Queen for Turks
black ones are still quite fast I
literally have no idea what's going on
oh no he's about to lose on time will
you resign now oh Patrick still doesn't
pass it please
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back everyone to our coverage
pogchamps five we just saw an
unbelievable match that was won by Sea
Dog over Jarvis and group a and he did
it in a couple of different ways like
pre-moving his way to a ladder Checkmate
like like a boss in game number one
succumbing to ridiculous pressure in a
crazy back and forth second game but
then going on to win in the tie break in
a relatively uneventful finish which
resulted in his opponent running out of
time but
Amman that was not what I expected and I
am so happy it was not what I expected
that was unbelievable stuff exactly
better than expected in every single way
doesn't matter who you're rooting for it
that was just plain fun to watch we saw
an underdog completely outperformed and
you know why it was so exciting for me
Levy is because in the first game
it seemed like it might be one of the
most boring matches of the entire POG
Champs like you did see some blunders
from Jarvis maybe some nerves
um but he totally turned it around in
the in the second game and then in the
tie breaks as well so just pure
entertainment and Sea Dog credit to him
for not getting discouraged after that
crazy second loss and
it seems maybe I have lost my co-host
let's take a look at our group standings
uh wow he was just so excited and then
we got xqc problems we gotta oh I think
my mom's back I heard his voice but in
the meantime let's take a look at uh our
group standings
we've got Sea Dog up top with Five
Points that's a line that's the number
we haven't seen yet
he got there by winning a game
and now rather winning a match with
three points now he won another one in
two remember he wanted the tie break
Jarvis with one point
and he got there by losing imagine the
tie breaks uh wild stuff I mean no no
obviously nothing else has updated there
has not been a match since yesterday but
the next match we've got for you is uh
sapnap it's uh ghastly I'm on
are you back and are you excited for the
match I'm here I'm more excited than a
couple minutes ago I mean did I just get
taken off air I was laying down a real
insightful I mean I was reacting man it
was Straight From the Heart there I'm
back Levy and uh I wouldn't wouldn't
leave you on your own this uh for this
next match I'm definitely excited to get
into this wet ghastly and sapnap if it's
anything like the first man I can't
yeah yeah Gastly uh is also I believe a
Pokemon uh that I don't think it's
exactly spelled anyways Gastly with an
HD the actual Pokemon am I missing
mixing my Pokemon it evolves into uh I'm
gonna say yes I think it is survey says
yep
yep I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure it
is anyway yeah we we we can uh go a
little bit deeper into these players
this is a group b matchup and Gastly is
returning after playing yesterday with a
with a crazy win over uh daily dose of
uh of I was gonna say of Chess daily
dose of Internet uh he's an American DJ
and producer maybe soon to be Canadian
once he starts Outsourcing some uh uh
licensing out some of his music yes Sir
Charles bronza in Canada uh he's played
many EDM festivals so he knows what it's
like to perform when a crowd is watching
and in POG Champs you already know
that's the case he's played 1600 games
on chess.com
and that's it that's all we have to
report for you today about Gastly now
he's also coached uh by Andrea botas and
there he is on stream it's nice that
chess.com put the pros and the cons on
that graphic it was like it's good to
balance it out you know so that was
that's great
you said that and you said that not me I
you know what that wow there was no
webcams on no one knows remember I'm
barely even connected here can you all
hear me that's true AI voice is uh it's
crazy nowadays maybe gasly said that
maybe Gastly said that but it's true she
has been giving him lessons and he did
play yesterday just like Sea Dog and
Jarvis both uh and yesterday he was a
fighter he was down in a couple of games
he fought back he's good in the end game
too we saw some good uh technique from
him
and uh he plays a lot nice nice music
and he he Vibes and let's take a look at
his opponent his opponent has the
distinction of getting five bullet
points on his card have you ever seen
something like this so he's winning all
right yeah and he's he looks like he's
got like a rainbow uh like a glass
reflection going on him uh he does
Minecraft challenge videos got over 4
million Subs on YouTube has played over
2 000 games on chess.com he's
again again with this bullet point I'm
gonna tell y'all some right now I'm
doing a couple lessons with my man too
you know I didn't make the bullet points
though Levy if he wins this match put me
on the card and if he loses keep Andrea
all right you know what and this is his
second POG Champs appearance uh and
there he is he was just Shadow Boxing uh
but he's rocking you know he's rocking
the the swag
and he's got the nice Studio set up
there he's looking confident they both
got headphones I'm on this is a
headphone matchup yeah no these guys are
locked in I expect nothing less from
ghastly like you know as any any DJ
producer like of course you're jamming
out to the tunes while you're playing
that's how I like to play as well so uh
we'll see if he's in the zone for this
matchup Levy yeah they they put us up on
the screen we were in Shadow Boxing uh
game started about five to ten seconds
uh sapnap has the black pieces in the
first game and I'm excited to let you
know that he might play a Scandinavian
defense we'll see what he's gonna do
we'll see if he plays in his comfort
zone uh I gave him a few lessons I you
know his black openings were all kind of
geared toward tricks like he played a
lot of England Gambit and I kind of said
look
if they know you're playing an England
Gambit in pot Champs they're gonna prep
for it and there it is
there it is now
he's gonna bring the queen out we we
talked a bit about this Queen's gotta go
here you gotta you gotta set it up all
right he might go there anyway but I did
tell him only to do it when the queen
was attacked and I kind of said develop
your pieces he's got very good instincts
so even when the position is not like
completely you know one-sided uh he he
he's good at handling things on his own
but we will see we'll see who he's
listening to coach Levy or coach Andrea
yeah well you know it's easy to tell
every good move will be coach oh let's
see this is a big moment because the
Queen's attacked and Levy he's almost
forced to try to find the best move here
it's like hey you have to move your
queen yeah and and he and he rushed it a
bit now he's actually 1600 puzzles so
like slowing it down in the game and
think and he could already get himself
into a little bit of trouble here with
Pawn to D5
come and get Queen D4 was right there I
mean it it worked but unfortunately the
opening
uh got a little bit oh my goodness we'll
we'll uh will he oh my oh oh he's so
good yeah the head is bobbing for gasly
as well he's he's feeling it he's got
the tunes on and you know what so
difficult Levy after Queen E6 check so
hard to move the queen again for
seemingly no reason and he would have to
to avoid this yep exactly right and the
crazy thing is like ghastly played this
move so quickly and queen D4 was right
there but it just it goes to show there
are some nerves sometimes when you start
uh in POG Champs not for ghastly who's
up to 1009 on the clock so
I'm just my head is subconsciously
moving just you know in sync with Gastly
I got it you know I feel compelled I
know he he he's head bobbing but listen
it's just the Knight who cares Queen e48
is going for Queen G2 sapnap is an
aggressive player that's how he likes to
play and
if in this position yeah Gastly just
takes I mean my God and and the worst
part is Bishop F3 and pawn takes Pawn is
so do you like this almost feels like a
gamble to me because Bishop F3 I would
say is almost the only move like that
idea is necessary for white if you don't
find it you may be worse so do you like
this kind of gamble with Queen takes one
well I think realizing Bishop F3 is one
thing but realizing Pawn takes B7 is
just another and and gasly is not
playing like a 700 one thing I have
loved about this event
wow is that the players are all over
performing they really that was and he
played the move so quickly and you're
right Levy if he plays on takes B7 this
could be an early knockout yeah it
really could be there are some you still
gotta you know you got Rook d8 at the
end but uh ghastly is is super sharp I
mean
what can you do right like that's
sometimes how it goes in the opening
sometimes you you get an opening and and
it it's in your favor it like you
actually get to a spot in in the opening
that you're playing but if you don't
take advantage if you let your opponents
get away with things they shouldn't it
you know it's bad things happening so
yeah Gastly recovers from the early C4
and I mean I don't I I told sapnap like
yeah what you were saying oh
you didn't tell about that move did you
that that was Andrea BOCES those are the
lessons with both yeah I saw actually on
the graphic didn't it say that he took
yeah
that's yeah that that is what it said
Gastly is ridiculous uh he is he's just
he's in the zone he's totally feeling it
right now moves are flowing the the
Bishops just dominated the position yeah
let's see let's see if you find spawn to
expand let's let's go check in
check it in with Gastly
[Music]
it's great we just get to commentate
with some nice Tunes yep I loved it we
gotta check in with casting more often
yeah this is how it was yesterday it
doesn't really speak it just lets the
music do the talking
right now he's not taking on B7 but you
know what if that's gonna be the kind of
mistake that you're making in your games
yeah let's bring it back to full screen
uh
uh he didn't find ponte's Pawn but it it
doesn't it doesn't it doesn't matter uh
his position is really really good and
uh oh snap can still be solid but the
problem is he can't even take here like
at some point White's gonna realize
Queen D3 is a good move too I mean
what can you say and you know what uh
Levy I do really feel that
um this game kind of reminds me of the
first game from the last match as well
it just feels so one-sided but that's
how chess is sometimes depends on the
opening depends how things shake down in
the first five ten moves I think this
was just a bad game for sapnap but I
could tell from the way that he started
the game that like he has some ideas
ready in that opening he just got caught
so I do not expect game two to be a
Stomp Like This
yeah I'm I'm definitely hoping hoping
not like and one of the ways you get
discouraged in an opening right you play
the opening you play it right but you
miss a chance and you're like I
shouldn't uh I gotta change everything
like no you actually just you got to a
good spot next time you just have to
take advantage and I mean we see Bishop
D6 blocking the queen in the rook and he
he won't have enough pieces in this game
to probably make a comeback given how
Gastly is playing but he always has game
two
and have two tie breaks today
that would be crazy from zero to two
um Bishop D6 the last couple moves for
sapnap I have been very very good uh B6
to avoid that uh pawn and then finally
Bishop to D6 to by the way avoid
Checkmate in one
yep uh I think we're checking in what's
up now we're gonna take a look at a
stream
see what he's thinking
you can bring this here
please
I see like massive blunder what is he
going for
you trying to open up is he wants to
trade that maybe
he just wants to just trade this
some I would do anything at this
one tutorials.com used to release that
sound pack
I like that yeah
[Music]
he seems concerned about Rook D6 and the
crazy thing is he's gonna bring the
camera E6 was actually
oh he just has a check he's totally
right what am I doing I'm just not
thinking out everything
here
[Music]
look at this song is just
this is inspiration for uh for for the
next ghastly song you know he could name
the song the G
yeah Gastly I mean he he's playing
really well don't bring the king up it's
not time to be a hero you literally walk
into a Checkmate if you do that by the
way yeah uh but uh I mean taking this
taking this it's he might think that you
know the F6 Pawn needs support and so I
could see you know I could see a world
where he calculates out can you say
yeah it's kind of one of those from bad
to worst situations right you you you
you see this and
unfortunately you you run into something
even worse uh yeah I hope he doesn't get
discouraged because the Scandinavian is
one of these things that if if you don't
practice if uh stuff like that can
happen and yeah Queen H4 is a killer
move to to get there with the queen I
don't know if he finds that like if
Gastly goes here I said it yesterday if
he finds a couple
sorry what was that what the man
like that's that's absurd isn't that
like a 1500 level move
I think Queen H by the way Queen H4 is
instead of capturing the pawn with the
Knight the pawn was hanging but instead
he's like you know what I'm gonna attack
it again to take it with a better piece
that's very advanced
yeah I mean
this guy is like gonna win this group I
I really don't know what to say uh he
he's playing at a 91 accuracy
uh uh he hasn't made a single mistake
like C4 right that was but beyond that
in fact he started with a mistake and
then he never looked back
and that's chess like that could go so
differently right if sapnap takes the
pawn
then totally different game totally
different game right uh and uh yeah
Queen H4 is crazy like to not play
Knight takes that was his last move too
he just played night there that's a free
Pawn instead he rotates over and
sometimes when we talk about these
things right like we say oh this is a
1500 level move there's people in the
chat like oh no it's not I'm I could
have seen that not in the game you
couldn't when we're talking about it and
we're showing you the arrows you're like
oh yeah Queen H4 but we all spectator
syndrome and chess a real thing right
like it's it's a lot easier
to spot things when you're not in the
game itself totally like
um I cannot even count the amount of
times that it was so obvious to throw to
a wide receiver and quarterback just
didn't do it like yep it was so wide
open and it was just unbelievable I got
I must have amazing vision
yeah if you had uh if you had the ball
in your hands Iman you would have done
it oh yeah
throw pig skin over the mountains
I mean easily oh Queen F6 and queen h8
and like that's it I mean that could be
it right in front of our eyes the good
news is this is a best of two and sapnap
gets white and sapnaps real good with
white and I think in general a lot of
the players are really good with white
Jarvis is better with white would you
saw him Crush uh daily dose of internet
was unbelievable with white uh I think
sapnap probably probably is the is the
same way a lot of these players just
getting going with black is very
difficult and there's probably a mate
somewhere there's a mate in two you
could also just eat The Rook
uh if he finds Knight C7 and queen E5 I
don't even know what I'm gonna do with
myself like if he doesn't take the Rook
okay thank you thank you thank you here
thank you
yeah this is like one of those uh let's
throw him off the scent you know Knight
takes A8 they'll have no idea
what if he promotes to a knight how
about how do we like that
um
I personally am a huge fan of that so if
you're if you're just asking me you're
just fishing out there I love it I'm a
fan
but he can come back and take the pawn
and then he's pinning the bishop and
then he's gonna Queen like if your brain
works that fast as a beginner like if I
go here then this but if I take that
because you want to get your most
powerful piece back in the game that
pins that now I'm re-enabling that like
you've got really good prospects as a
chess player if you if your brain moves
like that
yeah
the he's definitely uh and he hasn't
used that much time so what you're
saying is also totally true like these
are his instincts this is not him
spending 10 minutes and finding the best
move he's finding the best move in
seconds
yeah I'd love to I'd love to chat with
oh
my God it's crazy it's really impressive
this game this is nuts you know that
thing about the tie breaks and having
like the best accuracy yeah let's just
say if there's a tie break gasoline's
got the white piece like yeah straight
up
Yep this is check King B1 easy peasy
this man is up like 20 something points
of material is he gonna sack the queen
to make a new one or is he just gonna
give a little check sack the queen to
make a new one is absurd but
I mean okay it just comes a queen back
professional ever The Professional
no disrespecting the Queens
it's a good move Rook d8 maybe yeah
what's he gonna do he's not even fully
developed right like his Knight on G1 he
could just develop a piece and it would
be a great move
yep you played Queen A3 yeah hunt the
king
he can do whatever he wants at this
point
yesterday uh his games against daily
dose were were nuts uh and uh the first
one he was he was losing but he fought
and then he was he was winning and the
second game was crazy uh and and yeah
now the king is just going to go to the
corners there's there are some ways you
could mate Yourself by a miracle of God
like
like Bishop F4 B3 Bishop E5 is made
you know yeah
you have to be on the hunt for those
kind of things
if Bishop f4b oh snapdam just resigns
he's done he just yeah he doesn't even
want to and I don't you know I don't
hate that but let's go you know what
I'll be the contrary oh I do hate it but
I definitely am enjoying the celebration
look what the hell is this oh my God oh
my goodness fired up
oh my goodness he is crazy
oh yeah
Gastly takes a one to nothing lead over
sapnap
that that would that was like a
hydraulic press I don't even know what
to say I I mean sapnap made a mistake
early
it made a couple of mistakes but just
even the technique of of Gastly was
unbelievable life really was no you're
absolutely right Levy like it's hard to
give you know the appropriate amount of
compliments and praise but I totally
deserve uh ghastly with an unbelievable
performance but I don't think game two
will be that crazy no definitely not
right when you play Black you've got to
defend and and sapnap is an attacker and
uh he's gonna start confidently with
with Pawn to E4 and it's not really
clear what what gastly's opening
repertoire is but let's put it this way
you're not going to get a position with
two Central pawns and a fork and all
this stuff uh with the black pieces so
no sapnap's still very much in it
but not everybody is equipped to get a
game like that and go Shake It Off yeah
like no big deal it just didn't happen
like Jarvis right yeah Jarvis that
mentality Jarvis like felt like that is
exactly what he was capable of because
he just it felt like he was
internalizing everything like he he's
just nothing would faze him type of
thing so he had the right mentality I
feel like going in
yeah uh we've got a game two starting
very very soon
top half of the white pieces you
mentioned like these guys just feel more
comfortable with white you kind of
dictate things that extra move means a
lot at this level and you can start
and uh I I did mention uh two sapnab
that
he likes the setup I mean I don't know I
I don't know if he likes that setup but
he played it yesterday versus daily dose
and all I kind of told him was look The
Bishop's coming here so you know you
want to play night out and and go for
the queen side Castle right and go for
an attack that's what I said I mean
kind of like you know
simple and straightforward but there's
an entire game later right you got to
get the bishop you gotta get all this
we'll see if he does my strive he does
it his own way
God bless him but exactly because you
know Knight F3 could happen but the
reason why yep you've suggested maybe
the pawn to F3 is that when you do that
idea of Bishop E3 don't deal with Knight
G4 which bothers the bishop and maybe
loses it
yes that's exactly right although
yesterday uh Bishop G4 was played by uh
yesterday Bishop to G4 was played
by Gastly if I remember correctly but
there was a knight here so it's
incredible that he already he knows this
setup right like he knows the king's
Indian appearance defense setups he goes
here to take and then he plays Knight C6
E5 like that's nuts I mean it like he's
got the whole opening down basically
right and if we do have a look in on Sat
Nav I'd love to hear his thoughts like
maybe he's saying right now oh man
what did that what did Levy tell me to
do yeah let's go I'm terrified let's see
what he says so I'm gonna take that
push this use take
I don't really know
I just want to do this in Castle
you approve of 192 Levy no I kind of not
crazy not especially okay I don't mind
the bishop coming out now
um it's kind of funny because I I wrote
all the moves out to him
I was like E4 D4 Knight C3 Bishop E3
Queen D2 long Castle okay Bishop E3 is
back it's back on the menu it's not so
bad let's go and another you know uh but
we'll see we'll see right I mean
it's tough to reveal your prep because
if a future opponent plays the setup
with black now they kind of know right
but that this is one of the things that
black has to face is this and this this
should be three on its own it's fine but
we'll see if he plays Queen D2
that's right yeah and queen D2 on Castle
I have to say it feels like that's his
intention because otherwise he would
have castled right he would have Castle
kingside so I feel like I'm moving the
bishop instead of castling he's kind of
remembering what you were saying yeah
92 we don't love because it does block
the queen but
C6 is crazy because like does he even
realize that he's trying to play B5
I have no idea but C6 is an amazing move
and it's a flexible move because white
has not committed the king so if white
now decides to go this way that's
actually inaccurate because B5 hits the
bishop and if the bishop goes here the
B5 hits the beat the Knight and you can
take this if that man finds that I don't
even know what like who are we watching
yeah he is what a 700 but he's certainly
playing like 15 1500 level minimum
you know you're not you're not really
even like gassing him up because the
truth is uh
his setup yesterday was Bishop G4 and
Knight C6 and by the way Queen D2 has
been played I expect D5
if he plays B5 I will lose my mind
because it means he understands like the
ideas of the opening Beyond just exactly
I don't even oh we spoke too soon
Levy chess is all about how the opening
goes right it was it looked like gasly
was on another level in that first game
but look at sapnap he was gonna do that
move anyway well if you're getting a
free Pawn thank you very much I'm gonna
say right now if he wins this game
exactly how we talked about I am going
to be proud because what I said was oh
by the way there's B5 the game maker oh
my God
he baited you in Levy waited for you to
give some praise and then he said you
know what here's one to impress you as
well Levy oh my goodness B5 is crazy now
Bishop takes is possible I would keep
the bishop there but it's very hard to
do that you gotta slide back Bishop D3
is better because it defends against B4
which is virtually unfindable it's much
easier to find B4 with black than it is
to find B4 with white and anticipate
that right but
um
I mean this is a juicy attack if sapnap
puts h4h5 on the board
fireworks yep
because I don't recommend this but just
to illustrate how am strong White's
attack is if you played H4 while hanging
your Bishop it would probably still be a
fun attack we need this yep let's see
what savdam's thinking
and look I can't hate on Bishop B3 right
like that
feels like the better place otherwise
yeah if I move to here he goes here and
I guess I just push the pawn it's not
the biggest deal I think yeah if he goes
here I'm just gonna push my Pawn
I'm not really too worried about that
he's really can't like bring too much
out
in a castle Queen side I mean my queen
side's actually super protected here
I mean it's no big deal I don't think
if I go here
it's kind of a bad place to put it
unfortunately oh my God he played people
should we bring this to the big screen
I heard so many good things there first
of all E4 as you mentioned like what a
move but I also heard sapnap say like I
shouldn't put my knight on A4 that's not
a good place to put it it's a really
good thing for him to notice as well
B4 is unbelievable and yeah for for
seven I have to go I shouldn't put mine
out here it's good and it actually is a
very it's exactly right in this position
the Knight would do a lot better
rotating that way uh
now I I'm Blown Away by the fact that
gasly just hasn't even addressed okay he
misses Knight E4 which is very human and
now H4 is completely winning even with
Knight E4 That's How Strong the attack
is uh I'm really strong yeah yeah stop
that might just he might just do it by
the way because it's very much his style
the the thing is there's only one move
that he's really sort of Forgotten from
from the setup here and it's on death
yeah that would help his Knight get into
the action it would stop Knight G4 it
would guard the E4 that's just that one
move that kind of you know separates you
from someone a little bit stronger F3
would be unreal if you played that I I
think he's got
f3s yeah three is real tough like Queen
B6 the first thing that goes to your
head is they're a threat no now what do
I want in reality you're supposed to
scan and go can my opponent do anything
else and there is this uh the much more
human move is just to take this to kind
of like relieve yourself of the oh
that's absurd oh my God I I gotta get up
these two are they are both playing so
well
just I mean got a round of applause for
that move F3 so it looks like such a
small move but beautiful sets white up
for success and H4 G4 even Knight to F2
now
in it oh if he could just go he doesn't
even have to Castle
I mean this is
what's funny is we looked at another
like we did a little less than around
midnight a couple of days ago uh secret
chest training you know we only put
Andrea on there if he loses
um and and I kind of told him like one
of the strats is especially if they're
castled and you're not is to do this
like if your castle look at you can't
really attack but H4 H5 so if he if he
plays H4 it's like the the training has
all come together right and and that
would be
proud moment proud moment but it's a
very tense position Iman I'm I'm
terrified I don't know what he's gonna
do he shouldn't play E5 it's not what he
wants
that's right an E6 kind of indicates
maybe he wants to play D5 as black
um which would not be scary at all for
sapnap he should be very happy to see
that so E6 is one of those non-moves
that whatever you were going to do
keep doing it
yeah if I could highlight maybe a
possible mistake Knight to E3 is like a
oh let me like get my knight into the
game and totally forgetting you're
disconnecting your queen and Bishop
that's maybe the main mistake I could
see him making
exactly that is like the only mistake
you could make the 1983 just I'm getting
my knight in it's like no you're not not
only I've
I get it he wants to trade to reactivate
his Knight I don't hate it if he takes
with the queen I'll lose my mind because
the bishop is still there that's right
yeah the longer that Bishop stays there
like I feel like the easier it is to
either one of these players to totally
forget about it
please don't take it I think he had eyes
on the night yeah wow rejoining the
party the position just gets better and
better he he's just gotta go like he
gets this great position if he doesn't
play H4 H5
that's really the only plan of the
position for white and oh he already
said of that I'm gonna push he said I'm
gonna all clean
okay now big moment because once that
night moves Bobby by the way if it goes
to age five this game can be over
quicker than you think after G4
um but if it goes backwards like you
were highlighting E7 H4 is just ill or
yep H4 is brutal Knight H5
is a move that would draw White's
attention to how to get rid of the
Knight G4 is the first thing to go
through these these players heads and
that's it and then like what to find
Bishop takes and Knight G7 which is
unfindable I think at that level
but knowing ghastly he'll find it of
course yeah and
well we're about to see 97 and he he's
just gotta go he's got a
h4h5 gotta feel the energy
don't play F4 oh my goodness he's maybe
I'm on maybe he had to Castle and now
it's like a winter soldier and now it's
gonna activate he's like oh I gotta I
gotta attack oh but this is a fantastic
move
yep because you know what it is Levy he
heard the voice echoing in his head it
should be three Queen D2 Bishop H6
castle like he like had to do it before
H4 was even on his radar exactly but but
C5 is just incredible what a pawn break
if you take the Knight comes in now
you're playing defense the best move
here is to ignore it he he attacks but
the wrong way
oh but that's good because now he can he
can cocoon but but there's a mate coming
him on the B file potentially okay I
would say net positive for sapnap though
yes big net positive but Knight C6 Rook
B8 is so natural
yep H4 H5 how many moves are we going to
clamor h4h5 you know what H4 he might do
it now of course he'll do it now in the
one moment when there's a threat coming
for black you know
gonna play h4h5 and get checkmated
please know sapdam's gotta see it it's
that's we don't I had a feeling he was
gonna try to stop tonight and gastly's
good enough he's playing Rook B8 yeah
he's playing Rook V8 for sure
um so Knight A5 I think you might also
see
and and A3 was a mistake okay A5 we
don't care about A5 let's go let's get
right back to except that enough moves
on that side of the board maybe Knight
A4 one last move defend mate hit the
queen H4
out H4 here because why do you think he
played G4 was it like five
that's the wrong move right because you
got to think what's next and H5 is the
pawn break that gets you there and H4 is
a massive warning sign
for black
um and A3 was a huge mistake actually
because the Knight would get into B3 in
many lines the pawn had to stay at home
very sophisticated stuff H4 oh hey A4
did he did he like get the coordinates
wrong or something like he thought that
was H4 that was he got scared he's
getting scared yeah he's trying to react
but the pawn wasn't there was nothing
there right like and and there's nothing
there either by the way but he might go
B3 and it's going to be bad news there's
still no threat he might go Bishop B1
and inadvertently defend against mate by
the way
and you know I I feel like there's
um there's an important lesson here
which is like in general
you only want to make moves on the side
of the board where your opponent is
attacking if they have threats but if
they don't have threats make sure to
continue your own plan right now Levy
every single move has been on the queen
side so it's just benefiting gasoline no
matter what these Bishops have been just
like over here just hanging out uh
Knight to D3
Bishop takes Pawn takes Queen takes
loses the bishop and if that happens I
will be heartbroken because you could
have just
how's your heart heavy
is he feeling okay
your heart how is it you you can't even
script this stuff my man
I just forgot hey
okay
do either one of these guys know
that these Bishops
and take each other like they they move
in that direction on the diagonals
oh wow wow wow wow
wow
man poor Levy just had his heart broken
yeah that was tough that was tough that
was tough and uh you know I'm up listen
I'm only biased from the standpoint of
you know it was an individual who was
learning a lot and who almost got it all
right
yeah but ghastly has put up a good fight
and these Bishops are now monsters white
can still play H4 H5 but it's gonna be
crazy if this is the only Pawn sapnap
doesn't move I also am not a huge fan of
that move but I get it that's right yeah
no he's simplifying like he's trading
while he's ahead so you have to have to
like that from a simple standpoint but I
agree I was not
best
yeah
Bishop takes E2 is just trading down
and now I I I'm um is he gonna put both
Rooks like this which is exactly what
there it is H4 Levy just the way you
drew it up in practice right this was
the attack you were talking about yes
exactly oh my God he's gonna set up the
Triple Cannon
oh my goodness there's the attack it's
almost me
why did he not do that H5 Levy duck for
cover there's Checkmate coming whoa
it's really scary speaking of which like
if black plays
Actually I don't even know because even
G5 is like he might play F4 and then G5
Amman listen I don't know
I'm getting hyped
you're a good night for nothing my
friend broke B8 Ashley doesn't care
about H5 yeah if Gastly just plays Rook
B8 trades the queens and then he
actually has a fork at the end I mean
that would be Juggernaut level
uh
ah tough
it's such a Brute Force way to do it but
it actually works like it's it's so
caveman
he's just got three pieces I mean hey
can't do anything it works
nothing you can do D2 covered by the
bishop the bishop not even at the bishop
that we lost yep
uh the only way to defend against this
is probably to move the Knight
lose the pawn and then put the king in
the corner but it's it's that's
potentially a ladder mate
yeah wow
gastly's crazy Rook B8 is a is a top
tier move and he is crazy by the way
what is he coming in is that six nine
three beside his name like
he's nowhere near like he has some
mistakes this game but man is he strong
at that rating
yeah I don't even have an accuracy on
there uh for this game for some reason
but last game I I no no I I do see the
accuracy it's only 72 percent I guess
it's because of all the moments that the
machine was screaming for H4 yeah every
H4 was like this poor engine like showed
up to work what is his job you know to
provide the best move and then he's just
been ignored for the last 20 moves
yes 693 is just I mean I just got to say
it's it's totally ridiculous uh and uh
chess is tough right like you look at a
matchup like this and if White had just
played H4 H5 a bit faster instead of
playing C3 and playing on the side of
the board where he was weaker where the
opponent was trying to attack him
uh
uh would have been different but
and I can definitely speak to the fact
that when you're in the game when you're
the one playing
um basically everything is magnified so
yep when when you're sitting back not
even at our level 11 but even someone in
the chat when you're just not the one
playing the game it's easy to be like oh
that's not a threat that's fine but when
you're in the game like even the
simplest move feels like the end of the
world yep
yes it does King A1 by the way forced uh
will he find Rook B3 to try to get a
ladder because I it's ghastly so the
answer is yes
now there is a way that black could
could mess up which is Rook here and
then neither this nor this is a threat
oh
you forgot the important rule Levy it's
ghastly so the answer is yes the answer
is yes yeah yeah yeah well he takes
which is a good attempt but
unfortunately taking
is made taken take and take is made if
you take the bishop it's made on A3 I
mean this dude is unbelievable he is
he's cracked
Rook A3 would be wrong that's right I
mean but
it wrong in quotation marks yeah yeah
right
horrible blender yes
yes crazy I mean
okay so he is human sort of half human
yeah but he saw I mean it's not the mo
is it just me it's not the most obvious
right that that Bishop was attacked that
was a discovered attack it's true it's
true he he's doing oh Knight B5 is also
a very nice move by the way considering
the situation uh great move and uh yeah
you're right
um
given the circumstances he he scanned
all of his opponent's pieces and was
like am I in danger Rook his Bishop so
he just moved it yeah so I could say
like even if first of all if Gastly
understands that the a pawn should be
the target impressive if he goes
something like Knight B6
to Target it I could see things turning
around as long as sapnap creates one
pair of Rook
I think he trades one pair of Rooks and
I I can see him living and and maybe
winning this game I really can't yes
agreed Rook H7 is not a bad move right
this is already the beginning but but
the problem is if you start swarming
there's just an accidental mate that's
right that's that's the real problem
that's a great point I could really see
that happening because who's not playing
Knight D6 right yeah
absolutely everybody yeah and Gastly
could just start Pond hunting and miss
it because it's very easy to go that way
that way then take instead of you know
returning home uh there we go
maybe G5 at least there's no mate now
that's kind of a good thing yup
there is no mate he's gonna chase the
pawn down then maybe we give a check
can't get these Black's just so solid
that's the problem so solid
you know there is like a world where the
Rook takes on G6 and the black king gets
he played Knight B6 by the way he gotta
sneak in that's your only chance and
even that's losing
yeah exactly it's like you have to lose
this way this is the way to lose one you
could win the bishop okay plays Richie
when he's going for G6 I don't hate it
but Knight A4 is brutal
the only good thing I'll say is Knight
A4 brutal but the fact that your knight
would be hanging there might force you
to play Knight D6 which is you know not
a bad Square so it might kind of kick
sapnap and say hey dude you know bring
the knight in
yep Pawn to G6 is a thing still King to
G6 here would be a cold-blooded
defensive move kicks Out The Rook
holds the fort against the pawn that's
too much that's crazy
yeah King G6 would be nuts just
physically impeding the pawn from block
from from coming in but if there's a man
alive
if there is a man alive also Rook h8
would be kind of nuts like if he just
trades the Rooks it's like get them off
uh get them off the board G6 check
though by white should be the next
inclusion goodness
King G8 unpinning hitting the Rook
yup one minute now for sapnapping the
problem is G6 runs into a brick wall
like as long as he realizes there is no
danger literally at all Knight A4 is a
okay Knight C7 yeah yeah yeah that's
that's like last itch effort Knight C7
Knight D6 feels closer you know it feels
more dangerous but I think Knight c7's
the nasty move yes and he might do it
just because it hits a pawn and then
that okay hey Levy anyone's game I mean
it Knight c7's a big time move how hype
will you be if Gastly plays Rook F3
not that hype that's a that's an average
move for for gasly yeah
Rook F3 is game over white needs to find
Rook H2 Rook A2 at that point because
Rook B2 and Rook A3 are just mate uh
it's impossible to defend this Pawn
unless you play Rook B6 so it's very
easy to play Rook B6 because you go okay
I can't do this and then you play Roku
six but then maybe Knight E8
you know oh they ship a different way
100 really tricky 100 then Bishop h8
Rook H1 we got made oh he's he's
blundered 96 that was one of the worst
moves he could have played actually this
is what I'm saying so it seems like
you're being like aggressive with Rook
B2 yeah close to the king you're making
no threats yes you're making no threats
96 and now his idea oh his idea was
definitely to do something like that by
the way oh my God Levy it might be a
race Rook F3 Rook takes Bishop King h8
and they both have Checkmate yes they
both have Checkmate on the board as long
as sapnap doesn't take with a knight he
shouldn't do that he's very experienced
he'll probably take with the Rook as
long as he finds the other move this is
crazy
oh my God we might be seeing a comeback
for the ages here sometimes only got 47
seconds to figure it all out though but
a minute 36 and the tougher decisions
Gastly that's not looking like the
better side to be on right now no it's
not no it's not I definitely don't envy
him and this is very tough because you
do something like this to White you're
like he's got no moves Bozo made us
coming but all of a sudden it's all
turned around and it wasn't really The
Rook that was the problem it was the
king and right we got to give sapnap
credit for getting all his pieces
directly at the King this is called
creating chaos creating confusion in the
face of defeat and
one minute remaining on the clock for
black this is truly anybody's game but
right now it's a lot easier for sapnap
maybe Rook F4 to F2
and then you know you've got some ideas
for your own checkmates with Rook A2 but
you also I luck kind of defend the
Checkmate later
um down the line so yep and then there's
like Rook H1 and then there's Rook the
other Rook goes to H7 there's like some
crazy
oh my goodness I I think we might see
what we talked oh my goodness she played
it this is so insane he played the move
he played the move
and now so sapnap might think that he's
totally winning but for example Rook H1
Rook H2 by black if he trades those
Rooks Levy it's not that easy to win no
no it's not that easy to win he plays
Rook H1 Rook H2 he's gonna take he's
gonna take as long as he doesn't play
Rook H7 Rook H7 is is losing all of the
advantage it might not be losing the
game he plays Rook D7 right anywhere and
there's eight look the eight is made he
found it it's a Checkmate net that's it
the white king is gonna walk up to A3
all of these checks don't matter that's
nuts that was the most clutch move he
could have played it's made that's
Knight C3 it's made for both of them
rook d8 and Rook AJ and he's played it
Rook d8 made and sadness tied the match
unbelievable let's go to a live reaction
right here
yes let's go let's go
I fought for that let's go
oh my God oh my God I wanna go see what
they're saying I have to go see what
they're saying that was satisfying we
are saying only good things we want to
tell you what you were saying oh my
goodness that was Sensational what a
match that man that was that was Leon
Edwards Camaro Usman number two I mean
it was four rounds one-sided and he just
came back the night infiltration to tie
the match at one one Amman you called it
it's 1-1 now yeah one one and it was off
the back of that move I'm gonna go back
and give credit to Knight C7 that your
move was so killer hitting the pawn on
E6 and ghastly had a game in the bag
there but he had to play some specific
moves and blundered and immediately
sapnap took advantage and he never
looked back it was like perfect play
from there what a finish and by the way
in the final position Levy black had
Checkmate in one on the very next move
so if he didn't play that Checkmate he
would have got mated himself they were
both just hanging on a knife section and
and gasly was trying to check my the
whole time but he the the counter attack
was Sensational it's now one to one
let's remind everybody of what happens
when a Pog Champs match is tied one to
one after two rapid games they play a
blitz playoff three minutes per player
five seconds bonus on the clock we just
had it today but if you missed it it
that's it that's just one game and the
winner gets two points for the standings
the loser gets one not three and zero uh
the person playing with white is
determined based on the accuracy of the
previous two games among you called it
Char uh not Jarvis excuse me uh ghastly
in that first game played at around 90
so he's gonna play White he is going to
play White which is a big deal because
they both won with white yeah it's a big
deal like if you think about the games
how they went clearly both players were
more comfortable with the white pieces
Levy so while that is a big deal there's
nothing more you can do is sapnap right
I mean no obviously you know hey you got
the black pieces whatever you're still
breathing in this match with a chance to
win and he put himself in that position
so anything could happen I wonder if
these guys are going to be thinking
about that game and whether or not
they're going to repeat the exact same
opening because that's Scandinavian uh
didn't look good for either side in
certain moments yeah in the beginning it
didn't look good like sapnap could have
taken the pawn in the center if they
repeat it Sam might not he might I don't
know I I really I'm not sure so maybe
sapnap doesn't play his new tricks he
kind of goes back to his old ones you
just got to play fast you got to play
Confident uh we we saw we we saw neither
in the earlier playoff we didn't see
fast play we didn't see confident play
like right we saw exactly but and at
this point there's two different I'm
curious what the chat things you know is
it going to be a win for Gastly or Sat
Nav let us know because are you with
Team momentum Levy where you know
sapnap's obviously feeling it right now
or are you looking back at the white
pieces that gasly had in that first game
and saying okay well it could just be a
repeat of that uh yeah I don't know
about momentum right because it's
totally different to start like if
you're if you're an experienced player
here maybe what you do is you go scandi
was bad I'm gonna play what I know best
because I only have three minutes right
I'm just gonna play the opening I know
best which might be some Gambit right
like if there's low time on the clock
maybe I just go for a game but I go for
a cheese sapnap plays a lot of goofy
gambits that do not hold up in 10 minute
and five second bonus just but my God
are they lethal in Blitz right so we're
gonna see oh
here we go speaking of which he might
okay
that's gonna be a yeah wow uh he loves
his ponziani and and oh my goodness
sapnap runs head first into it you know
what's happening plays Blackburn's
chilling so
Blackburn chilling might seems like a
price it sounds like a price he he loves
checkmating people in eight moves my
concern was always this was was sapnap
what happens when they just you know
take the center and and this is the
issue with playing a Gambit repertoire
but the good news is give a check
develop you're not gonna lose that's the
good thing yeah
or ghastly here if he gets the push in
the center like E5 E5 to start hitting
those Knights once they develop that
could be uncomfortable
exactly not I see this is this is what
I'm talking about like it it just you
gave away the bishop that's a great move
great move from sapnap I just wish he
did it without playing that without
getting up the bishop
you know
um E5 is he probably doesn't even know
how fortunate he is that he played that
move yep yep I mean it's one move at a
time right because he would have just
played D5 he probably thought I'm
removing the knight from the defense of
the pawn little does he know right
little does he know um Bishop Free Pawn
by the way
clean Free Pawn on e4 I mean you got to
defend against the pin but it's a free
Pawn
and it's like does he remember
why he played D5 right it attacks
something
make it 97 again don't hate that move
not a bad move at all A6 next Castle's
next this is a great game so far
whoa
he's overloading the pawn to play D5 now
if sap dab sees this oh A6 is a
fantastic counter move
crazy but but only if he takes with the
pawn him on not if he takes with the
knife he takes with a knight it's game
over soon
totally
Pawn takes D5 maybe like cd5 yes 85 okay
takes I think savam's gonna take with
the Knight because he just put it there
will will she prove me wrong oh
strong
wow that is a strong move right there
that is a great move Center is staying
intact defended with the pawn uh both
sides are about a castle and it is a
it's a coin flip this game Levy there
are opposite color Bishops on the board
so I'm just gonna go ahead and pronounce
this game Draw yeah it's going to be a
long hard fall at end game Draw by the
way well both guys just hate the center
no one's taking a pawn uh it was winning
there for a moment de was just just game
over for black yep
maybe E5 now I mean he pushed one right
I love how he pushed that one he's still
not pushing this one
that's because it's under attack oh the
pawn is still hanging the immortal Pawn
they take that they move in the diagonal
direction right do they know that it's
apparently I mean I'm sure they did he
played C4 for a reason de is still a
good move I think he's gonna do it now
because it hits the Queen by the way
now it's not hanging so he'll take it
right
we don't we know how it goes Maybe not
maybe maybe we've seen this uh and then
he's got to realize his Bishop is
hanging
oh that's a good move too I don't mind
that at all
I'm just enjoying the show these guys
are playing well this is a fun match
this is a fun match and sapnap is
confident he's got 250 on the clock he's
an experienced Blitz player plays a lot
of Blitz
plays a lot of Blitz uh
I don't know man this is crazy Ed put
the queen in the center
yeah
it's a Juiced up Scandinavian
or no H3 just a simple move I like this
yeah we're gonna check in on sapnap see
what he's thinking about
this King so bad
is pesky Bishop did not forget about
that pesky Bishop okay
it's a good word
F6 would be insane if he plays it trying
to trade off Pawn to F6 bringing this
also good
what can you do what can you do is
pretty close up position I don't think
he can he'll notice that it's like you
know just light Square you might bring
this in this game and that's if he does
that probably just push this up take I
mean the time is not even not ideal the
time situation is a huge Advantage for
black wait what am I talking about yeah
if he does this I just go up one align
myself with this guy oh I mess up with
this guy
he's got good good columns right now all
right boom wait if I take take
let's see if I can get back yep
oh yeah he wants the meat
oh we might have left too soon we might
get a mate here F6 is ridiculous he said
let me trick him I think ghastly might
see it
but maybe not 55 seconds on the clock he
said let me trick him that's not even a
trick it's a great move because you
can't take I'm threatening to take you
so strong
47 seconds it's a two minute time
Advantage for sapnap live odds if they
existed would be very very heavily in
his favor as long as he doesn't panic
doesn't do something
rash Queen D7 Rook here Rook here
Bishop F4 played now he might start
gobbling but the best thing to do is to
keep the tension he already pointed out
Queen D7 oh this is this is so tense
it's a dead even position after Queen to
D7
and also Pawn takes Pawn if the pawn
takes back you could see Brook f8 and
maybe bad things happen
takes yeah absolutely right I'm shocked
that's not like a top move oh my God
he's tricking him again oh Queenie want
to sack the queen for the mate oh dear
me that's that's unbelievable
ultimate wait that's like a mic drop
moment in chess if there was one
now will gasly find Pawn to E6 turning
the screw
it's not the best move but it's very
practical H3 oh what that move is crazy
that is a crazy move now this doesn't
work I mean it's not terrible because
you get two Rooks but there's there's no
need for that slide out of the way
pretend it never happened
take the bishop do something take the
okay he's just simplifying he's going to
take this too probably
which is not good for him
yes it's it
oh gastly's yelling I don't know he's
yelling right now apparently he's Gastly
he's like hyping himself you know he's
like hey man we got to make moves you
know speed up speed up
[Music]
I will say people that listen to you
know EDM music in a puff when they're
low on time
[Music]
vouch yeah
yeah I guess you're really in the zone
he took a pawn by the way all right we
don't know what he's saying he stopped
yelling probably was motivating himself
let's go back we have a big moment in
the game a massive moment uh
gasly took a Pawn on C7 which was
inaccurate trading the queen was better
and then going here infiltrating and
taking everything over here it was a
transition to a rook end game that was
going to win him the game Pawn to F3 is
defending but now Queen takes D4 is a
check and a fork and picks up both pawns
if Savanna finds Queen D4 he has a
minute time advantage and he's got an
extra Pawn in an end game but that's it
he's got to see Queen takes Pawn
um
we're all waiting in anticipation
yeah I mean takes Pawn it's the only
attempt
wait it's on the board sapnap lost
connection
oh it it's like it's on
you're on the analysis board you tricked
me
no it's on
it's not on my board but it's on it's on
gastly's board
ghastly sees it right because we we have
the production here so we see multiple
screens there it is it just got played
wait that I don't think that was a
server thing was that a server the
hiccup or was that the sound apps
looking around like he can't he's
looking for something
okay he got some time back it seemed
that that was so ghastly has connection
someone doesn't have connection Queen C5
is he found the move
wait this is exactly how like the anime
Arc would go right you know disconnected
he's like they've been trying to take
him off the server didn't even want him
to win he's back he finds the best move
you know this is the hero's story yeah
yeah yeah yeah that was the uh
I don't know what's going but sap dance
not moving I mean it seems like he
oh oh oh my goodness
the CH I see people in the chat saying
they've disconnected come on no not at
this moment
really
oh no gastly's also lost connection they
can't see it but we see it on our on the
side here oh
this is chaos and I'm I'm sorry but
I I'm I'm just enjoying it I'm sorry I'm
gonna go out and I'm gonna say it
pure chaos and I'm here for it
uh it's on here the madness no one knows
how this is gonna be resolved
this is crazy this is so pure Madness
everyone in the chat is stuck they're
glued they can't go anywhere they need
to see the conclusion to this show this
was a queen and Rook endgame to
determine who is going to win today's
matchup and now I don't know they're
gonna tell me to go to a break I don't
know maybe maybe we don't go to what if
we just hijack the show they can't oh
wait they can't force us to go to a
break never mind they can include the
button they can they can click the break
button yeah they can mute our mics well
I'll just have a hot mic permanently and
I'll just oh God I is that what's
happening is that what's going on we're
waiting to see if we can it was
it was heating up Levy but I think
because of what's happened it probably
is time for us to take a step back but
man that wouldn't have happened at a
more inopportune time we'll have to sort
things out right yeah we'll have to sort
things out we also by the way my
analysis board just updated
so we're gonna go to a very short break
we might we might be back in a few
minutes don't go anywhere we're about to
clear things out
[Music]
thank you
oh wait what I ah I'm making ah what am
I doing
Child's Play really oh no Jarvis no
Jarvis what does that move Queen trade
seems smart
is there something smarter ah your own
person to me bastard forgot about the on
person just hung my Rook
[Music]
I'm not a concerned at all I'll play the
god I threw that so hard holy
one on top
[Music]
thank you
welcome back everyone to our coverage of
POG Champs five things are absolutely
insane right now in our last game of the
day potentially we've got to look in now
to the Gastly stream
the guys were playing so let's just get
into it yeah let's just get into it this
is this is gastly's second Queen end
game in two days yesterday he was on the
fortunate side now he's going to be
losing his Pawns in front of his King
which could prove fatal
he plays he's about to make a move
what we see draw here I oh snap's
repeating but
I don't oh that's
that you're gonna lose a lot of Pawns
with check uh oh deceptive doesn't want
to draw it's crazy a white was worse
yeah why it was worse this is crazy it's
just it's a feast wait why is sapnap not
taking the Pawns
does he think he's gonna win with white
oh my it's just a drop he played if he
repeat moves
I think they drew right yeah
but what was the logic what was the
logic can we check in on September
stream
nice tie the game
I don't know I might have had a win I
don't know
okay I don't know if I had to win
so and at the same time though you have
to see it from their perspective as well
like the game was kind of all over the
place like I don't know I don't know
probably both happy they didn't like the
time or something so end of the day like
I think draw is kind of fair result and
fight again you know yeah it's one and a
half one and a half after three games
you're right they do fight again uh this
is the first time we've now had a tie
break end in a draw so that means that
the players switch colors it means that
sapnap now gets a uh game with the white
pieces I I don't even I I mean I I don't
even know what to say this is
a tremendous amount of fun he was
definitely better at the end of that uh
Queen end game but
what a fight thus far I mean what a what
what a day of games we've had yeah no he
was better at the end but uh I I'm not
like
it's not insane that he didn't uh take
the pawn in my opinion I I think he was
just comfortable not losing the game
probably both sides you know fight
uneven terms in another game and as you
mentioned white pieces or uh or sapnap
so he's going to be going back to that
same setup against Gastly and levia
could come down to that Queen D2 Bishop
H6 stuff that we were talking about yeah
I don't know I I'm assuming Gastly is
going to play the same way it's three
minutes five seconds bonus Winner Takes
it all and some of you may be wondering
uh what happens if they keep drawing we
stay here forever yeah it never ends oh
wow
oh wow okay the Vienna oh and sapnaps
playing a Vienna Knight to F6 is the
response and he goes for the Vienna
Gambit
and he's are you like perked up in his
chair there he I think he knows a thing
or two here
I I also think he knows now that's not a
good move because you can take and put
the Knight into the center with the pawn
but does he remember that okay he takes
taken Now Pawn to D4 is vicious the
Knight is gonna get stranded if it goes
there E5 removes its guard and if it
goes there you push the Knight back and
then you just it's foot on the gas is
what it is yeah basically E5 no matter
what
yes he might go deeper he plays E5 what
a confident move the knight's gotta go
back he's gonna play Knight F3 Bishop C4
this is an opening very much very much
in his wheelhouse Queen E7 is not a good
move because you just you can play
Knight F3 wow honestly nighty ate's an
impressive move like yep it's the best
move and it might look like nothing when
you when you just glance at the move
quickly but every other night move was
at losing the Knight immediately so it's
really impressive he not only found the
best move but the retreating move as
well yeah I mean there should be four is
a nice move but but this is a moment
where he can he can run literally run it
down mid we had Tyler one on yesterday
Bishop 52 is a little passive but it's
obviously not bad but you've got to step
on the gas like right now Bishop out you
don't want to take because you're just
removing a pawn from the center he's got
to develop as fast as possible and black
is getting back into the game but it was
you know
it was good there for for a moment it
was really really good really really
good yeah as you mentioned D5 so one
thing that I will say that's working in
his favor is he clearly is aware he
should castle inside and I like that
here because I think as you've
highlighted with the arrows the D file
might open up so I like the long
castling yeah and he's in the way of his
own Bishop so hopefully he just castles
Queen side and and gets it over with
because there's no other way to make
progress right
uh he's out of the opening stage yeah
see he takes which is like I kind of
thought he would do that
because you just want to do something
because you know you're better right so
now D5 is winning because of that's a
crazy move but it's not good it's it's a
so it the the thing with this move is
now he is a tough decision yes
so easy to blunder here so easy to
blunder so his Queen needs to stay
exactly where it is because the Knight
that he put there his own fancy move it
actually can't survive there without the
PIN it would just be hanging yeah he's
gotta either take with the Knight or the
or the king
and ironically the best move is King
takes which I don't think you can play
it's so hard to play that
what what's he thinking oh he took with
the queen
oh he lost his Knight
is it gonna be taken because remember he
didn't take it last move he might be
under the impression it's okay
so let's let's hear what he's thinking
now because I think we're gonna get the
reaction to him losing that night
I up
he has a free night why
why why why must I do this to myself
his next few moves let's pull it back to
the big screen
um
it's gonna be very fun when we mute that
whole highlight into just beep beep beep
beep
um
he can just play Knight G5 and keep
moving forward like it is a long game
it is a long game and and you know if
rookie one is a good move but he is down
at p is down tonight there is no running
away from that it's a long game but not
that long
it is a three-minute game so just
um they'll at least be used to it
because they did play one last time
yeah they kind of played a 12-minute
game last time because of the you know
server issues yeah Knight A5 is crazy
and you can't take because it's defended
and you know the smart move here is to
retreat because you don't want to trade
that's right
love Bishop be here um because I think
if he just keeps the pieces on the board
Knight G5 is about to be a major threat
yep
and Rook seat is it might happen for
black but it's a little bit easier to
attack for white because just much much
more common pattern
wow on the board unreal down a piece but
totally playing not just to like fight
on but he's playing to win and G5 is a
huge huge move next
yep Knight G5 is on the way
I'm assuming you could play okay that's
I don't hate that move but I I don't
like the knights they could get like you
know and also another thing Iman is do
we really want to open White's G file
I'm not so sure that's true I I really
do get the feeling that gasly could play
Queen F6 at any moment I some reason I'm
not sure he's fully aware or at least he
was aware the queen was guarding the
Knight but he might forget it later
oh very easy right because
you're sort of like ah I'm gonna go over
here and you go oh and then you do the
sapnap reaction Bishop B4 is a nice move
Knight F6 now Knight F6 but
you like Knight F6 and then what's
White's next move right and and then you
gotta go back that's the thing
yeah the best move is to completely undo
your move which is not a nice feeling
yep
Knight F6 is a really high level move
so it's just any night night oh nights
oh my God
wow
it's not the best move but it I I mean I
like like for this level but it's still
I mean queen D3 right yeah
and we're still in business for both
sides honestly
Queen D3 the best move for black is to
play Knight F6 defend against that hit
the bishop and then yeah Queen F2 makes
a lot of sense but Queen B6 is now a
made threat Queen B6
and Knight F6 is such a good move
because imagine Knight F6 Bishop takes
B7 oh I won a pawn and those mate
threats start to really hit Queen B6 and
Rook V8 yeah I mean oh he's played it oh
this guy that's an insane move that is
an insane move sapna might think that
he's hung the Knight and queen B2 is on
the board I just played B3 oh he's
played B3 that's unreal that is unreal
and now two knights are hanging for
black and he might think he's messed up
Knight C3 is probably what you should go
for here both guys are playing out of
their mind
unbelievably clutch chess Black's time
is down to about 10 seconds within white
this is
on a really unreal Knight C3 you take
the Knight you can come in with the
queen but then by a miracle the king is
safe on D2 and and then it's game on it
totally and these guys are what like
seven eight hundreds this is such a fun
and high level game to spectate
unbelievable sapn's got to be brave he's
just got and and I got news for you it's
so in like it's not human to take the
night you would much rather move the
Rook up but but that's how you get
yourself into trouble he's just gotta be
brave and run with the King just take it
and run Rook Rook D3 Knight takes Bishop
Rook takes Bishop all of a sudden
there's even more pieces hanging it
still is not over nope definitely not
over Black's gotta find Bishop F5 or
maybe take the Knight set now it's just
gotta be brave he's got 20 seconds he's
got to make a move he has some great
gift by the way Knight G5 Queen H4
that would be that would be crazy to win
like that Rook D3 I think the most human
move yeah now Knight takes Bishop is
okay he has played it don't take the
other Knight because oh my God that
would be sad but rookie four
gotta be with the Rook yeah no no Bishop
F5 would would be
utter insanity
Bishop takes Knight is a move that does
make a lot of sense yup
you know the more I'm looking at it like
Bishop F5 is is possible for Gastly he's
been playing some absurd chess today
oh oh oh the bishop has fallen and
there's no mate we'll sap that misses it
his one chance okay but Bishop takes
Knight now
surely he's he's up a piece he wants to
trade oh but it's made oh mate on C2 oh
dear me oh it's mate oh it's made on C2
what a tactic if he plays rookie too
then he's just a fighter yeah and saw
the mate he saw them but the Rook is
hanging did did Gastly see Queen takes
E4 it's in the middle of everything
Queen E4 could be the end of the game
here he's missed it too Pawn takes or
queen takes oh my God Pawn takes and
game on the Knight is trapped on A3 yep
rookie three okay he's come back he's
looking for back ranks that's what
statnap is doing right now and it's very
easy oh my oh my gosh there's like all
sorts of cakes takes rookie hate oh D5
has played C5 and the Knight needs to
rejoin the action yes Rook takes Rook
takes there's B4 and the Knight is hit I
mean that that just finding that would
be a huge B4 and take the Knight somehow
okay brings the queen
Knight D5 just to escape time situation
in mind here even though black has an
extra Knight
everything to play for for white oh mate
on C2 from a different angle
wow King B2 we need to see King B2 he's
missed it Queen's a queen C2
Levy from downtown
oh
it's crazy
glad we got that reaction there oh Dad
that was that was a match for the ages
board Vision Queen from C6
over to G6 two and a half to one and a
half is the final score double High
break double
OT Levy we've had tie breaks in both
matches today you remember when there
was like four matches on the docket
yesterday and there was only two today
yeah I think the two matches made up for
it in entertainment oh we just gotta we
just got a Bonus Match that's that's
what we got that Queen G6 Queen C2 uh
oh my goodness uh that reminds me of the
Miami Heat uh play call you know uh uh
Lebron James three-pointer no good rush
back out to Alan his three-pointer bang
I mean that was Queen just setting up
Queen C2 time and time again time and
time again what a mess Shivers I
what what can we say we do have a
scoreboard for you uh in group b Gastly
on top with five points out of a
possible six uh defeating daily dose of
internet and regulation uh and then
defeating sapnap in a double tiebreaker
can can they just split the three points
like why does SAP only get a point for
that like I that's
entertainment like the deserve the
deservo meter is going crazy right now
that was so entertaining but honestly
ghastly
the way that he used his Queen to
threaten Checkmate multiple times that
game while potentially hanging other
pieces so impressive
that I I I couldn't have said it better
myself
um we are going to be right back and we
are going to get an interview with
Gastly because we've all been dying to
talk to him don't go anywhere an
interview with Gastly coming up and
we'll wrap up coverage of POG Champs 5
day number two
[Music]
oh
no
[Music]
foreign
click the Subscribe button see if it
says subscribe free and purple and if it
does you're golden Ponyboy anyway let's
check on who's priming right now
oh it's my friend
um
Willis hey Willis can't wait to grab
lunch later catch you on the flippity
flip anyway back to the chess content
you guys have a good one
he's I was here I was I was lost oh okay
well hey hey let's go oh no I think I
should have just done that
beat it let's go no 15 unreal no first
try eight in a row nine in a row baby
let's go
let's go I gotta oh cool I got a little
achievement thing I honestly really
enjoyed that that was really cool become
a chess.com Community streamer at
go.chess.com start streaming
oh yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
come on
let's go
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
and there we see ghastly celebrating
what was a montage of Victories tough
decisions good moves in his match the
clutch Bishop takes H6 the final
Checkmate the celebration do we have to
get the cartwheel too
and we have to do the cartwheel Let's
see we got it we got it we got to see
this car surely they didn't look at the
cartwheel oh that red areas
we're joined by by Gastly I I wish we
had a chance to chat yesterday after the
matcha versus versus uh daily dose
internet too but we
we had a time uh restraints but yeah
dude welcome to the show uh what an epic
first two days just can can we just get
to know a little bit more about uh your
chess journey I mean maybe just you as a
person you've played twice now in the
first two days and you're five out of
six
yes sir thank you very much for that I
appreciate it um yeah so I I picked up
chess like randomly I was just sitting
on a plane and I realized that I had
never played it you know I wasn't really
particularly inspired by anyone or
anything I was just like I don't know
how to play chess and I feel like that's
a life skill that I should have and it
the bug just bit me and it never left
um and ever since that I've been
practicing like practically if not every
day at least five times a week like
really authentically studying uh the
entire uh the opening principles for
black and white and uh it's it's been an
awesome journey and I'm like so freaking
grateful to like be a part of POG champs
as well like you know to go from oh I'll
pick up chess at the latter half of
December to now winning two matches I'm
I'm very very blessed I'm very grateful
for it
yeah and honestly man I'm not saying
this to gas you up after this win but
Levy and I were looking at the rating
that you had it's like 700 and total
Joke Man you played way stronger than
that and you were finding moves after
moves so I'm just gonna say you're
definitely worth more than that I wanted
to ask you because uh I mean over at the
chess brought Channel we just we rock
out to EDM and techno music while we
play chess all the time so like were you
listening to some beats while you were
playing man yeah I was actually I was
listening to this uh this mix by this
artist known as uh mph miles per hour
and and it's this like all unreleased
mix it's the same one that I was
listening to yesterday I I don't know
it's it's got It's got like it's like
audio testosterone or something I don't
know what it is but it helped me get
through that match Big Time
yeah I mean you were sniping Queen the
queen maneuver in the in the final game
uh the first two games were like were
you were sueded but the comeback was
crazy from your opponent and uh I'm I'm
gonna confess something uh I trained
your opponent a bit like I I trained him
you know if you had asked I I would have
been cool I just we just didn't know
each other so I was slightly biased if
you re-watch the commentary don't hate
me I just wanted a close match but you
put all that to rest like it didn't
matter man I mean we were sitting here
going we were saying moves and we were
like he's not gonna play that like if he
plays that he's gonna win the tournament
and you've done that multiple times so
wow that's awesome that yeah that means
a lot coming from you guys yeah
um and uh and you know you're you you
trained him really well because he
scared the crap out of me there were so
many moves where I was like okay he
definitely saw through that but um uh
Andrea did a really good good job
training me I'm I'm very grateful to her
for like you know helping me realize the
the main principle of Chess is
trying to understand what what your
enemy is trying to do like yeah
everyone's got your you have your plan
but if you just tunnel vision your plan
you'll always hit a brick wall and you
have to you know adapt it and it's a
it's a beautiful thing very grateful
yeah
hell yeah man congrats again I I wanted
to ask you one last question because I
think you are honestly the longest match
that we've had so far in the competition
you went to like double OT so like are
you fatigued at all were you like
feeling nervous towards the end or are
you feeling pumped up
uh certainly felt nervous I felt like my
guts were gonna come out of one of my
orifices I didn't know which one but at
some point I was definitely I was
definitely wigging it out no sapnap was
uh he's a great opponent
um and uh but you know like when I go on
stage and I perform for uh you know
thousands or whatever amount of people
that does not even come close to
comparing how nervous I was during this
match not even close
that's wow that's wild because I I did
say during your the player intros I I
kind of said right I said uh he's played
on stage uh and and that might translate
but it's true listen I've played these
matches too I've Iman has commentated on
me playing and I was in the headphones
and the nerves are ridiculous like you
don't even see the board straight so uh
but it you clearly saw it well enough
because you won and double overtime uh
you you won yesterday and I think
starting out according to the official
uo you you were like rank four like
maybe that's not exactly accurate but
you are outperforming all expectations I
am just so excited to see your magic
it's virtual who's supposed to be the
best player in the group you bought it
you better change all that you better
get a nice little uh eight you know
eight out of nine points
um
listen thanks so much for for joining
this interview I can't wait to watch the
rest of your games you play chess like a
like a professional I can't believe
you're not four digits of Elo so that's
what I'm saying uh congrats again my
friends I really appreciate that
yeah we'll uh we'll let you go get some
rest uh spill some stuff out of orifices
it's not too late to do that uh if you'd
like
um I think I might take advantage of it
yeah maybe yeah it's not you know not
not on camera but yeah no congrats again
we'll uh we'll see you for your third
matchup very very soon absolutely thank
you fellas have a great day cheers
there he goes
that's that was a lot of fun and these
are our group standings uh little update
to Group B we've got another five points
uh a tie break win yeah I mean what a
match that was right like that was just
two incredible matches today you started
the day by reminding me and our viewers
like we haven't had a tie break yet I
was like Hey Levy what's the tie break
format you're like hey shout out man we
ain't gonna have any tie breaks and then
look at that two tie breaks today double
overtime in one of them remember the Sea
Dog victory in in OT as well a cartwheel
the the cartwheel the prayer the the
everything I mean yeah those are all of
the complex emotions that go through a
chess player's brain and we saw on the
screen there Queen to C2 Checkmate over
from G6 with just unbelievably clutch
stuff
uh
what what to say I'm on I don't know
Levy it's been I honestly do think when
people uh you know saw the matchups and
they were oh it's only two match-ups now
they were thinking okay it'll be cool
but like maybe not as entertaining as
day one
I'm just gonna say we blew day one out
of the water the day two was crazy
double overtime over time it both
matches yeah it looked like a crush at
the beginning of both matches but then
epic comebacks from The Underdogs just
so sick to watch it exactly right game
one was rough game two in the second
match was rough for a while and then
just an unprecedented comeback just
well we've we we've said it enough uh
day two is in the books Let's look ahead
for what's tomorrow uh I will be here
once again uh and I will have another
co-host I think I'm going to be with
Alexandra tomorrow we've got four
matches we had five then we had four I
think it's four now we'll start tomorrow
with a Frank versus cycuno that's a
group a matchup for you Frank Victorious
versus Jarvis and regulation saikuno uh
succumbed to the Monstrous 1200 rating
and then daily dose of Internet versus
sapnap so we get sapnap right back in
there with the one point versus daily
dose who has yet to get on the board
both victims of none other than Gastly
and then we will finish the day off with
Group D getting their first matchup I
did a thing versus papa plaza we've got
a little World Tour Germany we got xqc
representing Quebec Canada and I don't
know maybe wherever he is now versus
tyler1 I can't wait for that one
hopefully xuc fixes his computer
hopefully Tyler one doesn't issue me
another ultimatum of ten thousand
dollars so that would be that's like for
sure the Epic matchup coming up but
finally Group D gets to play that's uh
that's gonna be exciting and I I do want
to say you know we've been talking about
how great Gastly was and totally
deserved but uh shout out to The Losers
of today's matchups because like just
such epic play by them
um just so so impressed that I feel like
I'm gonna take a moment and just make
sure we credit them because even though
they didn't win the match it did get
credit they got some points for their
efforts and it looked like they were
getting blown out of the water and they
made some insane comebacks so that's a
fun thing Jarvis nearly pulled off the
greatest
upset yeah I mean really like I I mean
there's been a lot of events so I I
haven't heard I don't remember all of
them rather the second match was
Sensational too uh this has been a lot
of fun we're gonna end the show but
before we let you go we gotta tell you
about these really cool twitch drops
that have been a part of pogchamps five
and I just want you not to miss your
chance to cash in on them all right you
can earn two weeks of a diamond
membership by watching two or more hours
of chess with participating streamers on
Twitch you gotta connect your Twitch and
your chess.com accounts to claim the
reward drops are only going to be
available for a limited time so you
don't want to miss it use command drops
in the chat
to learn how there you go
awesome
we already put in a couple hours
watching us so they were they're already
in I know my friends
I'm on well like you you could you could
be included in that too I was signing
off everything production I've got a 10
second countdown it has been a great
pleasure to commentate day number two
for you of POG Champs five we'll get out
of here and we'll see you all right back
here tomorrow for pox Champs five day
three
the problem is the bishop is no longer
hanging oh he knows what he did hands on
the face
ouch oh it goes from bad to worse oh he
knows about the ladder
smoothie so smooth to see if he yeah he
does it that's the first song in pop
Champs 5 right there what is he reading
right now
closer
[Music]
make a move he's gonna run out of time
the position is the bishop he he's lost
always lost something I'm not happy with
how I played today I feel like ass oh
snap them just resigns I definitely am
enjoying the celebration
and he's played it once again has tied
the match yes let's go he's missed it
Queen's a queen
what a move let's go
[Music]
see
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
awesome